Wait is great.
Oh,
okay.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by camera's seen games maker
of bullied slinger.
What's blade slinger blades linger is the first video game that's being released
by kerosene games.
A new company,
a startup.
We believe in them bur roadie Stevens would say positive energy.
Um,
we were taking a chance with them because I think they're doing everything
right.
And what their goal is is to make really fun bad ass games for the IPAD and the
iPhone and android devices.
The idea being that most of the games you're getting like the really good games.
Like if you,
uh,
even like doom or something like that,
they're porting them.
What are you doing is playing the noise?
You have like a soundboard now are you going Adam Carolla on me,
bitch,
they,
um,
they've made these games specifically for the IPAD instead of it being ported
over.
So all the,
the,
the controls are very intuitive.
And with the,
the graphics power that you have now on iPads,
it's just fucking incredible.
You can play like really high resolution,
just unbelievably beautiful games.
They're really fucking fun.
So if you're into like wasting your time and getting your life sucked into a
little piece of metal and glass and I know you are and as I am as well.
Uh,
it's a,
it's an excellent game.
It's only two 99,
so it's very reasonable.
It's called Blade slinger and it's by kerosene games and you can get it right
now on the iPad and I believe it will be available next month on android games,
but it's available for iPad and iPhone right now.
You're dirty fucks were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n,
I t and Brian Cowen was just in here bragging about the hemp force protein.
I really,
so yeah,
that's amaze.
Fucking delicious.
You know,
why is this?
I'd be like,
there's other protein that you can buy,
like hemp protein that is,
um,
it's,
it's good.
You know,
you'll get protein out of it,
but it's much grittier.
It's a,
it's got a different set of keys to that,
that the,
the,
the chocolate nature of it is so delicious.
And those bars,
I've eaten every brother.
Next time we'd go hunting.
I'm bringing all the,
I'm bringing,
that's what I'm bringing those guys.
They're so good for you,
but they're just that delicious.
Those buffalo bars.
And then not only that,
the protein bars,
the protein bars were making the hemp protein bars.
It's the,
with hemp protein.
Um,
there's varying levels of,
uh,
of protein content and varying levels of a refinement.
Like the best protein is like,
it has a,
the best hemp protein,
the best hemp hearts have a higher level of protein,
but it's more expensive.
It's hard to get that.
Well,
that's what we get and we,
it's harder to get to the point where we can only buy 50 pounds of it a day.
So we run out of hemp for sometimes because it's so fucking delicious.
I'm not playing the shit up.
It's got raw cocoa in it.
It's got Maca in it.
I'm telling you it is.
The best stuff in the wash is fucking no sugar,
no sugar.
This one gram of sugar,
which is just sort of naturally occurring from the,
uh,
probably from a,
just from the vegetable matter,
but it's,
um,
sweetened with Stevia,
which,
uh,
in low doses like you're getting with this is,
it's Stevia is incredibly strong and you don't have to put much in it to sweeten
things.
Like if you ever put Stevia in your coffee,
you'll really fuck up.
If you go with a full tablespoon.
Brian,
you've done that before,
right?
Remember when we were,
we had Stevie at the house and you were accidentally like put too much and
crazy.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it's really sweet.
And it's weight gets the perfect like for this,
for hemp force,
it's really the perfect sweetener because it is unbelievably healthy.
Like if you look at what's in,
you know,
from,
from the protein to the Makkah to the,
um,
to the rock,
what does Maka Maka has?
It's a,
um,
well,
I'll Google it so I know exactly.
So I don't misspeak,
but it's a nutritional supplement as well.
Some crucial testosterone and all of a sudden man was supposed to get,
you don't dare call it is,
I think it's from a root or protein.
Right.
So it's um,
hold on a second.
I'll find out what the to not have some kind of,
I'm going to find out exactly,
exactly.
Maka shit be haunting over.
It's actually,
that's interesting.
It's also a nickname.
It's a nickname for English speaking countries of Anglo Saxon heritage.
Hmm.
Huh.
That's weird.
I've never heard of that before.
At a certain time,
you know,
you got to let shit go get your nickname would be if you are a fighter.
No,
I wouldn't mind my payment.
Maka Maka Callan.
There's a gross man.
You make your own.
Make your own.
Like fucking the dinosaur from hill.
I would call me like Brian the sometimes irritable Callahan is this shit.
Right?
Okay.
It's a root.
Yeah.
From the Andes in South America.
A root.
It's a member of the radish family.
It's been a long forgotten herb until recently apparently when people started
using it again.
Any updates on that ting situation?
Yes.
The Ting I fucked up.
They,
they did tell me that they were dropping it down to 25 bucks.
And I think I said that the thought there was a shitty idea,
but when I said it,
I was high so I forgot,
I'll send emails,
I'm high and it's like somebody else did it cause I just fucking don't have any
memory.
Like I looked at my own writing that this guy had sent me back.
I was like,
that looks like exactly how I would write it on.
And it was like,
I guess I just had one of those books sometimes,
especially if I get out of a tank when I get out of tank,
if I go into the tank blasted and then I get out for the first few hours,
I'll write things down and then I'll come back and read them.
And I feel like some spirit from the 15th century,
you know,
like fucking,
if you're riding an old English,
I'll just write in a weird way.
And it's like really atypical,
you know,
just cause you're getting out of that fucking nutty experience of the tank.
Um,
so yeah,
the same thing was a,
it is $25.
They decided to lower it.
It's still a great deal if you just Google a Tang reviews.
I was reading some last night all positive.
It's all excellent customer service.
There's so many excellent things about tank.
The,
the customer service,
the,
the ethics behind the company,
the fact that there's no contracts,
you know,
the fact that they,
they,
they offer,
they give you credit on your minutes.
I mean,
it's just,
it's a,
the way it's set up is beautiful.
And,
um,
the idea that you can just cancel at any time is really what everybody supposed
to have anyway.
That really is what everybody's supposed to have.
You really supposed to have service that you can just quit on.
You shouldn't have to fucking get stuck in some shitty fucking contract.
Well,
with,
um,
with ting,
it's a unlimited devices.
You have an online control account control panel where you can like see your
usage while things are going on.
So it is no hold customer support.
It's a,
the way,
it's a anytime between 8:00 AM and 8:00 PM the,
uh,
you call on a real person picks up the phone.
It's like they're trying to do everything in the right way,
you know,
and I think,
uh,
it's possible to do that and still make money.
And that's the philosophy behind honored as well.
The philosophy behind on it mostly is sell you the best shit,
the fruit that we can find all the shit that we use.
Um,
the best in nutritional supplements,
the best vitamins,
like the purest shit,
the purest protein powders,
everything we can get the best and sell it to you at a very reasonable Bryant.
I mean,
we sell those Blendtec blenders now we sell them $200 below the rent
manufactured suggested retail price.
Um,
same thing with battle ropes.
Like the cheapest battle ropes.
He can find everything we sell.
We sell the best shit where we,
we have like a really unique distribution method.
I mean,
we were in,
we have all the stuff,
we send it out ourselves and we just buy massive quantities of whatever's
awesome.
And,
uh,
we,
we don't have to worry about this traditional methods of advertising.
You also use everything you,
yeah.
Yeah.
I would never sell you anything that I think sucks the fat one.
Yup.
Not even sucks in a little one.
I need some socks.
Socks are skinny one.
We call it the Pesky truth.
You've got to live in the truth.
Yeah.
If you don't socks,
it's,
it's not,
you know,
and people would question that and they can question that.
But I think it's pretty evident by my actions.
If you don't think so,
please let me know.
And either you're a Douche bag or on a delusional,
one of the other,
I don't know.
I'm not,
I'm not banking on either one,
but,
uh,
I,
what,
what I'm doing,
being involved in this company makes me happy and the company makes me happy
that the people behind it or they're just super cool people,
you know,
from Aubrey all the way on down that are trying to sell the best shit possible
at,
in a really ethical way.
A hundred percent money back guarantee in the first 30 pills by it.
You don't like it,
just fucking get your money back.
You don't have to return the product.
Nobody's trying to sell you anything.
This sucks.
Everything that we're selling it on,
it is just literally the best supplements possible.
And we're bringing in more stuff every day.
We're constantly bringing in food.
We have all sorts of stuff now from,
um,
from things for children to,
you know,
um,
different protein bars and,
you know,
the buffalo bars and just again,
anything that we find that we think is really good.
Vegas support protein bars.
We have the Vega powder as well,
which I like.
It's a,
it's a hundred percent vegan protein.
Uh,
it's non hemp,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
you can get it like pea protein's great.
I,
I take that stuff as well,
like a way,
no,
I think your body doesn't digest it as well.
It makes me Fart.
[inaudible] fart like crazy.
Yeah,
I think it's delicious and it is effective as far as what if you don't mind
fart.
I just don't,
I don't,
yeah,
I don't fucking know.
And I'm processing.
Tait Fletcher used to eat that shit and his farts,
we've talked about it ad nauseum on the show.
They were on on ball.
Unbelievable.
Like you couldn't believe a person could make that much odor come out of their
box.
Like old sour milk tastes gigantic sulfur teach huge,
you know,
so he's like,
it's a 240 pound guy,
shit in this out.
So it's just like,
whoa.
And he's giant,
tall.
So it's like all this room for air.
He can all get down and make it sound far out of his body.
Just was not the way to go.
If you want to smell someone's ass,
we also have killer bee.
Honey.
Why don't we have killer bee honey?
Because killer bees sound like someone you'd behave gangster as fuck to rob and
steal their honey.
I liked the idea behind it.
It's Hawaiian.
I don't think it's any better than regular.
It's probably not even as good as regular honey.
I don't care.
I'm going to take it.
If there's killer bee honey on the shelf and it's right next to regular honey,
I am that stupid.
I need Kaler Bihar.
And that's why we have it.
So we're selling killer bee honey.
But it is delicious.
15 years ago we've proved our retard to
when we,
we,
we had no intention of fighting our dogs cause we wouldn't do that with our
pitfalls.
But I had to go,
I had,
I had to go find a pure breed game bread from a long line of gain bred dogs
pitfall.
Why?
Cause it just had to have it cause it's a fighting dog in case a dog breaks into
my house.
It'll fucking take that dog out.
And you came with me.
We're driving around and we find this one guy who had an advertisement,
our dogs bread right out of the box.
We were like,
we have to get that
idiots.
He had a lady,
it's,
he had a really interesting setup man.
He was so open.
Like that guy could have got arrested like so easily.
He called it going to a dog show.
It was interesting,
you know,
cow.
How open he was about it.
It's like wow.
Like you've,
you're breeding fighting dogs and you're fighting these dogs seven years in
jail.
Those guys who were involved in that.
It's a,
that's a,
that's a cruel fucking way to live.
You know,
that's a weird thing.
Like they engineered an animal that wants to go to war.
He told me,
he said,
these dogs live with their life on the edge and it became a chain.
And I said,
when she,
when Bam,
Bam was a year old,
he tried to fight a female and I called him up and I go,
the dogs trying to fight females.
He goes,
yeah,
that'll happen.
I go,
well,
well how do you get an to me?
He goes,
ah man.
For me,
I gotta,
I gotta wipe the dog.
I've got to wipe the dogs coach and then put it on my mails nose and then lead
him up to it.
Even with a muzzle,
I was like,
fucking,
I don't want,
I don't want her to talk like this.
It's a stupid,
and then of course the dog killed a cow
and fucking two wasn't a good dog.
And by the way,
we don't sell that dog@ana.com I kept that talk.
Can I get,
you only get cool shit.
You use the code name rogue and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Brian counters here.
Yes.
Okay.
That's great.
Yourself,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
So Brian,
Brian Kalyn
and I are ready to take it to the next level on the 14th.
Uh,
Steve Rinella returns to the podcast and uh,
we'll be discussing future hunting dates.
We're going to do it again.
I'm excited.
We could have a show,
we could have a show just,
you know,
like it would be the best show in a stupid networks.
You and I hunting like a couple of times a year and it cut it up into,
you know,
like a bunch of different episodes because I mean,
think about how much funny shit would happen.
There would be a lot of people angry at us.
What we're doing though.
Wow.
A lot of people be,
Blake,
you're hunting.
No one ever has ever mixed comedy and hunting,
so they should all come.
No one's ever mixed case fighting and in comedy either.
That's true,
but that's apparently that works.
Yeah.
This works too excited.
So where are we going hunting?
We are going to,
we might most likely Alaska.
Really?
Yeah,
but are we going to hunt hog there?
No.
If we do it between now and August will we'll be going to Alaska.
We'll rather um,
we could go and hunt bears,
which I didn't want to do for a while until I started watching all these Alaska
shows.
I had a misconception about bears.
First of all,
I'd misconception about whether or not they're delicious and apparently uh,
black bears are,
they taste really good and people love him according to his book,
depending on what they've been eating.
But yeah,
they're eating blueberries.
It tastes literally like blueberries.
Yeah.
So you want to go with the blueberries are,
and you shoot them in the spring and apparently the delicious.
Yeah,
I just was,
I was not in the,
I'm definitely still not into shooting anything that I'm not going to eat.
I don't want to kill a bear though.
I like Paris.
Why do you like bears?
I don't know.
I just like them best can suck my deck.
I don't like bears at all.
Why?
Because they're assholes.
Bear bears,
don't give a fuck about you.
Bears have blank eyes and they would eat your face if you stood still.
Bears,
bears don't even kill you.
Do you know what bears do?
They just start exceeding.
Yeah.
They just start eating this.
Don't be in their territory.
That's a tricky thing with,
uh,
with omnivores like chimps,
same thing.
They just start eating well,
chimps,
I talked to the guy at San Diego Zoo and he said,
I said,
you don't have any chances.
He goes,
Nah,
just bonobos.
I said,
well wait a minute.
They have Banabos in captivity where,
and uh,
but I was I think in uh,
um,
yeah,
they do.
And um,
uh,
San Diego Zoo.
Really?
Yup.
And that's interesting.
You share their born almost.
Yeah.
I,
for some reason I thought that no one has been almost in captivity.
They're amazing.
They're,
they're uh,
their,
um,
because the matriarchal,
but they fucked so much.
I,
that's why I thought that no one has said that vanilla is,
are really sexual.
And he said,
chimpanzees solve everything with violence.
He said that the first thing you'll see with chimps is they'll have scarred up
risks because the minute they get in a fight,
they cover their genitals cause they go for each other's balls.
So it's so you can't breed said that's why they go for the face and the genitals
and your hands.
They want to scar you up.
They want it.
They want to finish you.
Yeah.
This is one of the,
I guess the San Diego Zoo is one of the first zoos to uh,
to have them.
Yup.
I went and saw it there.
Quite possibly the most intelligent primates on earth of than humans and um,
they have,
uh,
they have Benobos well that you're going to watch a fuck show if you watch them.
Cause if you go there,
all they do is fuck.
Yeah.
What's a female dominated society,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a matriarchal society,
but it's also a completely orgiastic like everybody fucks everybody except the
mother doesn't fuck the son.
That's the only the family online they draw.
Yeah.
If your mom's hot,
you're,
you're out of luck.
But I guess you could just fuck everybody else.
The good news is you can fuck your dad.
So couldn't use everybody knows everybody.
Imagine father's day,
how horrible that would be.
Bears are beautiful to look at and everything.
And don't get me wrong,
I mean I think they're beautiful but bears are ruthless,
heartless,
emotionless monsters.
That's what they are.
And for the moment,
for that matter,
for the most part,
they're not attacking you.
So our opinion of him is based on that.
But the reality is they can attack you and when they attack you they might as
well be a fucking werewolf.
It might as well be some Munster from the movie that doesn't exist because it's
just as terrifying.
Well since you said that we were going to go hunting in Alaska in August,
I think like 20% of my brain every single day and that's large percentage is
constantly occupied with the hybrid possibilities of,
of a polar bear slash grizzly bear.
Thank you.
Global warming coming into our camp.
Cause remember polar bear will stock and hunt you your meat.
And so I'll be sleeping in your tent.
Just so you know,
and I'll be,
I'll be sleeping with a handgun.
Polar bears are the only barriers that are completely carnivorous.
There's no vegetable matter where they live.
There's no fruits,
there's no anything,
and they don't.
So their bodies are not designed to process that.
And then also the only mammals that hunts people actively,
automatically right from birth.
Right.
They see people and they're like,
oh wait that.
Whatever's moving.
They're like,
oh,
eat that.
Well they,
they,
they had this,
they had this baby polar bear.
It was a small,
like an,
it became like,
you know,
it was probably three months,
five months,
whatever.
They couldn't put that into a cage with the other polar bears.
Not in a million years.
They would eat it.
They would eat it right away.
Right away.
Anyway,
cannibals,
they live in the most ferocious environment.
Grizzlies are cannibals to grizzlies killed her pups all the time when shit goes
bad when they're running out.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They kill their cubs and they eat them.
They eat their own babies.
They can suck it.
Okay.
I'll shoot them right in their stinky heart.
And not me.
I like Paris.
No,
no,
no.
I was trying to kill you.
Yeah.
That's different.
Yeah,
you would have,
I'll have my guns at the ready team people bitch.
Okay.
I'm not saying she's gone.
She Chrisleys I don't want to shoot grizzlies cause apparently grizzlies he
can't eat.
They don't taste good.
I guess it's because of their,
they're such predators.
Yeah.
Which is weird because mountain lions are 100% carnivorous
and you can eat them and apparently they're quite tasty actually according to
Steve Byrne Ellis book,
they,
they are,
you got to cook them for a long time and yeah,
it's a real catch crap shoot a lot of times and not tasty.
Oh really?
And you eat and sometimes people in eating a Grizzly,
uh,
or,
or uh,
with,
they've been eating fish.
It's going to taste like fish.
It's going to be like,
yeah,
but I like fish.
Well yeah,
but apparently it's not a good tasting fish.
The other thing about,
the other thing about bear that he talks about his book,
cause you have to,
you have to cook it really,
really well cause you'll get trick and osis and other things because yes,
because they eat rotting meat.
They come across,
you know the Caribou though.
So the same with hogs.
Yeah.
Which is actually one of the reasons you don't eat carnivores.
They always say that you're not supposed to eat carnivores because of that.
They carry a bit odd because you eat fish and fish are 100%.
Carter was,
yeah,
most sex means,
I guess a few of them.
He'd vegetables those little pussies.
It's the exception.
Yeah.
It's interesting isn't it?
I mean,
look,
think about lobster.
Lobster.
They eat nothing but rotten meat,
the bottom of the ocean.
And they're delicious.
The best tasting thing ever.
A lobster.
And I think shrimp are related to Lyse and other insects.
They're related,
the roaches.
And when I read that,
I was like,
oh we found out that were related to roaches on fear factor when it guy had an
allergic reaction.
Who's eaten?
Roaches was allergic to shellfish.
Whoa.
Same thing.
Same enzymes apparently.
Yeah.
Well you look at it,
I mean it's real fucking similar.
You know crab is like a fixed shelled bug.
Yeah,
exactly.
The same fucking thing seems a spider.
Apparently.
Spiders tastes good.
Really big.
Fat Tarantulas.
Very crab.
Like really you?
Yeah.
If you cook them right?
What about all the spines?
I don't know.
I guess you burned them all gets you burned them off.
Yeah.
Since those fuckers off because I'm trenchless they have those little weird
microscopic little fibers that dig into your score.
One of the things I took from that trip being out there in the middle of the
Atlantis is how fucked you would be if you had to go hunt first of all,
girl by herself.
Cause you'd freeze to death and I don't give a shit what anybody says.
Secondly,
if you had to go hunt your own food,
you'd be out there cold and hungry as shit without it,
without a prayer.
It's a hard man.
And even,
I mean the bat like what we were at was at one point in time a notion and it was
like really clay.
Yeah.
There wasn't a lot of like vegetable matter,
so it was really weird the way you were walking around with these gigantic empty
hills all over the place and you'd get to the top of one and it gets really
freaky when you get to the top of them.
And then you look out at how big this area where there's no people is.
Yeah.
I mean it's unbelievable.
Vast fuck.
And you can fall and you can fall.
And by the way,
there a cactus is everywhere.
So just,
just at the very minimal,
you're going to be dealing with a pain in the ass.
Yeah.
It's so harsh.
And that's why when,
when Brian and I were there,
the uh,
Steven Noah explained to us that this is where Lewis and Clark had gone.
We actually camp and the same campground our first night where Lewis
and Clark at stayed.
Yep.
And um,
a bunch of people tried to live out there.
They tried to with the what's called homesteading and they give you a piece of
land and if you can farm it for like a couple of years or whatever,
I had to grow like dry weight,
I think it's called.
And they just couldn't even do that shit.
It's mud.
Yeah.
Everything is just gooey.
Bottom of a lake mud.
Just hating life.
Yeah.
It was like the Great Western inland sea,
I think it was called.
And there used to be dinosaurs there and it's a really freaky plus Clark when
they went through that area I read,
didn't see any native Americans.
Yeah.
No black feet or anything because uh,
they just,
they couldn't live there.
Yeah.
Apparently they would visit it every now and then a hunting trips and then go
back.
But that's it.
And that's,
you know,
when you get into like a sparse sort of a situation like God damn,
we got to go find those fucking crazy deer in the badlands.
Yeah.
Cause those deer just running around.
There's not that many of them.
And there's the occasional mountain lions running around jacking him.
It's crazy.
We found mountain lynch shit.
Did you see any of that up there?
No,
it was fat ropes of hair.
That's where like,
like shit with heron it.
Yeah.
You know,
that's when you know something's been jacking people.
Yup.
Or Jack in the deer's rather.
Yeah.
It's a harsh place,
man.
If you had to live there,
I'm not really sure you could you,
I don't think all of us,
the guys that were there and we had the like
even even living in like that,
like if you look at the New Guinea,
uh,
that the,
the like in New Guinea,
Papa New Guinea where if people had been living for forever,
they're mostly malnourished,
always were because they had to eat like things like,
um,
uh,
Barc route and things like just stuff that just grows in swamps that has no
nutritional value.
You have to harvest a insects in the air and make mashes of them and roast them.
Socks.
Dude,
I was just like,
this is fucking shittiest life in the world you'd spent all day.
Not only he's spending all day fucking harvesting bugs in fucking bark route.
That's it.
That's delicious.
But then you're most likely to die from um,
inner tribal conflict.
You can only have small tribes.
You know,
you couldn't,
you couldn't support a lot of people on sets this little food.
She had to walk around in small bands of families and then they'd come across
each other and be like,
you're in our territory.
And it'd be a fight.
Yes.
Fucking yeah.
The um,
the fly sandwiches.
Yeah.
Fly.
It's fly balls.
Fly Ball eyeballs.
That is the craziest thing to do with mosquitoes too.
Yeah.
They take a net and they think,
well they use a,
they use a pot,
they take a pot like a metal pot.
They wing it through the mosquitoes over and over again and they stick to the
bottom.
I slam on the bottom and then you like do like this with your hands and make a
cake of it.
And then they fry the cake.
They make mosquito hamburgers.
Have you seen it?
You've seen the video talking about yeah.
It's so disturbed.
Yeah.
It's a ball of carbon bug that that part of the world sucks up fat one.
I,
I'd move lots because that's what it is.
It's like they don't know what the fuck to do,
man.
Sam Sherman and lived
with the intuit,
you know,
and he was like,
it's your,
you,
all you do is you eat,
you're going to eat meat and see how if you didn't catch a seal that winter,
uh,
you were living in the dark eight months
to live with them for,
for like adding a week or something.
He's written this book two weeks,
but he said,
everything's a refrigerator,
right?
So you got the,
he,
he wore these wolf mittens.
There's wolf for mittens and you just would leave mount side.
They didn't,
weren't cured.
You just leave them outside.
So when you actually skin an animal,
you can actually wear the fur without curing it or worrying about it.
But like you're always the,
he said,
well,
you guys really a master fisherman and stuff and the woman goes,
we used to freeze and we used to starve to death all the time.
We would end up and end up trying to kill our dogs to eat.
The problem is you couldn't kill too many dogs cause then the bears would come
and kill you.
So you were just always living.
So if you didn't get a seal,
one seal that you were done for the winner because you didn't have oil to burn,
so you were living member.
It's dark 24,
seven,
sometimes for four months of the year,
five months,
year,
you're,
you're living in the dark,
eaten raw fish in your Igloo.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
That's what it was like.
Can't see anything.
So you're not going anywhere.
Oh,
you have no fire.
You staying in your Igloo and you're hoping you have enough fish.
There's no firewood.
Right.
There's nothing to learn.
Now they would burn,
they would burn a fucking,
uh,
oil.
Yeah.
She's,
how's that rice?
And they would align their regular,
this is with like seal for,
but nothing just keep you warm.
Right.
Nothing.
Just body heat.
Yeah.
And,
and they,
they've anatomically,
uh,
evolved so that their hands and feet don't get cold.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Yeah.
That's freaky man.
It's freaky to realize that that probably only took place over a few thousand
years.
And they all have frostbite on their,
um,
on their faces,
on their cheeks.
All of them.
Yeah.
Whoa.
All frostbitten cheeks.
They just deal with it.
Yeah.
I still got a scar.
Scar tissue scar all over your face.
Yeah,
he,
they would get around on smushed sleds.
They still do.
And then now that you snowmobiles,
but he was like,
you know,
you're on,
you're on a fucking your dogs and only w I think it's only one species dog,
not huskies.
There are type of Husky,
the only one dog about 45,
50 pounds.
Those the only dogs that can survive that,
that can live in that,
that,
that cold.
Yeah.
What a shit way to live.
But what an amazing thing that people are willing to try it.
I think like anything else,
human beings get used to anything.
Anything you,
when you're in jail forever,
you get used to,
you figure it out.
And when you want,
rich people are fucked.
They get used to being rich.
That's right.
So you're used to being a lazy,
like kids born rich.
It fucks him up.
But it's called the wealth of cap,
handicap of wealth.
Do you worry about that with your son?
Do you think like that and make sure this little motherfucker like,
yeah.
Yes.
Develops and discipline.
I was going to say one of the ways out is sports.
Yeah.
And learning how to lose properly and then he had a win and you know,
that's a very huge,
it's huge.
Sports are teach you how tough or you're not and how to lose,
not just how to win and mainly teach you how to do things like recognize
plateaus.
You know,
people always,
that's why I always tell young people I go look accomplishment.
When you're to accomplish something,
all you have to do in some ways is have a good teacher so you're practicing
correctly and show up every day and you're going to find long time periods of
time where you just hit plateaus.
Where you know,
I tried to write today and I just,
I was like,
my head was all over the place.
Why it doesn't matter.
The point is,
I tried to write,
you just show up every day,
you know,
take,
you can take your breaks of course.
But you know,
for the most part you've got to kind of like familiarize yourself with the,
the peaks,
valleys and plateaus of accomplishment you run.
One of the things about sports is that the competitions are clearly defined
there.
They're very obvious if have you been successful at getting the ball into the
hole?
No.
If not,
why have you been successful at Po,
you know,
wrestling people if not,
why?
Yeah.
You know,
and you either adjust and work accordingly and use your intelligence to sort of
figure out whatever puzzle it is,
whatever game you're playing and whatever the parameters are or you don't.
It's that simple.
Whereas like socially,
there's a lot of bullshit and there's a lot of gray area and you know,
you might think you're cool because you listen to the right records and you
dress the right way and you live in the right neighborhood,
but really not really.
Not really.
You don't have any character because you've never had,
it was about the sat.
It was about to say that,
you know,
I,
if I was just thinking about it as she was saying that I think socially,
whether or not you're most entertaining person or not,
I really think that a huge,
huge way to fix a social issue you may have.
It's just be honest,
like you and I always talk about like,
just,
just don't lie man.
Don't lie to your friends.
Just be really honest about it.
If you haven't problems,
if you have like an issue,
whatever it is,
if you're open and upfront about it and don't take yourself too seriously,
if you can do that,
it's very high as a lot of personal assessment.
Well,
this just,
it goes back to sports or any thoughts on it?
Especially martial arts.
I've always said the best way to stop bullying is a teach.
Everyone had a fight.
Yeah,
and you know why?
Because the big guys won't be bullying if third,
they're actually training and learning how to fight.
I don't know.
Good fighters that are bullies.
It's much,
much more rare than regular big people who aren't bullies.
That's right.
Regular big.
There's a lot of bullies,
especially if they're like insecure and that's the only thing that they have.
It's like a girl whose personality sucks,
which has got big tits.
We're gonna see those tits everywhere she goes.
She's going to make sure she knows where,
you know,
where her asset lies,
personal assessment and due to become bullies.
It's like,
what do you think?
That's it.
You just brought up something that's interesting to me,
like about the way to teach,
stop bullying.
See terribly.
If I wish I couldn't agree more with it's true,
what would you do?
So what would you do about this?
This,
this gun issue that's a much more complicated issue than just bullying.
But I think it could solve the,
I really do believe,
cause you said,
what does it mean,
uh,
this do,
do,
do you have armed guards?
I mean,
is that how you stop it?
What do you,
there's a bunch.
There's a bunch of issues with,
um,
the,
the school shooting thing with many mass shooting,
any,
there's a ton of issues involved here.
And not in the least of them is the mental state of human beings today.
Take medication aside.
You know,
put,
put it,
put it as a variable.
I know a lot of people resist that variable,
especially people who are proponents of a antidepressants,
especially people who have enjoyed the effects of antidepressants.
Cause apparently,
and Chi antidepressants can make a lot of people happy and I'm not disputing
that.
But there's,
um,
there's something going on with the state of mind of a human being who's willing
to do something unbelievably horrific to affect a large group of people.
That is the,
it's gotta be the result of that sort of mass scale destruction.
It's like you want to affect people in the most horrific way.
This guy was shot children.
He wanted affect people in the most,
most horrific way.
Why we have to get to the root of that.
What makes a person do that?
You can't do that.
Okay.
You would never do that.
I know.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I know you,
you would never be a school shooting.
You'd never shoot babies.
So who would shoot babies and why?
What the fuck makes a person like that and that's not the gun issue and that's
not a fertilizer bomb issue and it's not a nuclear issue.
It's an issue of humanity.
What is it about us where we have failed as a culture so much that even we have
one example out of a million like that.
How does that happen in a community of people who can read,
who are aware of each other's presence?
How can you get to a point where you got a guy like that who's willing and able
to do something like that question.
Then from that is I,
I think I've always been what you,
what you just described a lot of times the one in the closet,
definitely one of the classic definitions of the Sociopath,
a psychotic sociopath is they,
they will do something horrific to watch the effect.
That's how they get power.
That's how they get pleasure and there are a lot of different examples of that
and so psychologist,
I read a book called the sociopath next door where she talks exactly about that
though.
The other issue might be if we agree that we've always had,
we're always gonna have sociopath's it's an aberration in the gene pool,
a culture or whatever like that.
The Guy,
whatever the guy from Columbine,
one kid was suicidal,
the other guy,
a kid had a history of being sadistic sociopath or another style of it.
Bernie Madoff.
Different sacks.
Exactly.
The question becomes,
I guess,
is there a discussion to be had about how to keep these lethal weapons out of
those kinds of people's hands?
It's a,
if it's a public health issue,
you know,
um,
and we can figure out a way to get these people at least monitored or helped in
some way or not or locked up if there's no shabbats.
It seems to me that,
that,
that the variable is the availability of lethal guns.
Now I own guns so I'm not,
I don't really know how to address,
I don't know.
The Pr,
I don't know how to address.
Very interesting point and I think you'd be silly if you didn't agree with that.
The issue is though that the national rifle association and gun enthusiasts in
general are not willing to give any ground whatsoever and they don't want it any
more because want to be able to own these guns,
they want to be able to go out and buy.
Like my friend Anthony Kumina,
he has a 50 caliber gun.
It's like,
it's like I can shoot a hole through a fucking building.
It's in fact against the Geneva Conventions.
I believe you can look it up and you can't use it against personnel because
you've come apart while he has one of those.
And why does he have one of those?
Cause he's crazy.
He wants to own it.
But I'm not worried about him shooting up anybody.
He's,
he's just a gun enthusiast and their,
uh,
their thoughts are they should be able to be a gun enthusiast.
And I agree with that.
I agree with that as well.
If you are a,
I'm a law abiding citizen who follows rules and regulations and you know,
you're not an insane person.
You're not a sociopath.
And Anthony's a perfect example of,
he's not none of those.
It's not a bad guy.
He just wants to be able to have that gun.
And the,
I feel that he should be able to do that.
I really do.
I mean,
it's crazy as it sounds.
Well,
I mean,
I own guns and I don't want somebody taking my guns how much horsepower my car
can.
I don't want someone telling me how warm my house can be.
I don't want someone telling me,
you know,
how much fuel you using.
I don't want,
I don't want that.
I don't,
I don't believe that you should be allowed to control very much about other
people's lives when it's not affecting you.
Right.
And you know,
there's all the arguments about the use of fossil fuels and using your share and
all that.
There's,
that is not the way to handle that.
By stopping people from using this technology.
We've already developed a technology.
We're going to have cars that run microcar runs the runs on 50 50 miles before
it needed to gallons.
You have a golf cart,
you don't have a car.
It's a dishwashing liquid.
Manly about bugs you doesn't terrifying.
He hates my prayers so much in you that that wants to come out and said it would
would come out with a Shelby gt 500 that's what you need to get ahold of.
662 horsepower.
Yeah,
baby would have real v eight six drive the speed limit.
Just again thinking,
Ooh,
you want to feel that I haven't did much fucking seat.
You say that because he never had one.
Trust me,
Jesus Christ son,
trust me.
Trust me,
the shelving and trusted me.
Yes.
Get a fucking American muscle car,
man.
You have to get an automatic.
We'll get a challenger SRT eight beautiful things.
Yeah,
it was a big fucking Hemi in it.
Then make an automatic for pussy like laughs at me.
He's like,
Hey,
if I can tell you he can't believe I drive a Prius car,
you end Fitzsimmons.
Fitzsimmons at least admits it though.
He loves cars guy most of my life I don't think that way,
but just,
I'm just so lazy with cars.
I literally got it cause I didn't want to get out of the car as after this.
Let's go to the Ford dealership and go for a little drive.
It's not pushing me,
man.
Come on man.
No peer pressure.
If you want to get something reasonable,
get like an m three or something.
Get something that's got some packet pickup.
Shut his mouth.
You were going to get an Audi.
What happened with that?
I just found a cramped.
If found it cramped,
crampy a five.
I was like driving in a lunchbox.
I liked the feeling of the my,
my,
my Prius was like half as much as money and cheap and I n I only had to get out
of the car.
Do you have to get out of the car three times more with an Audi?
I was like,
I'll just drive this.
It's easier.
So lazy when we got to get you doing more podcasts so you sell more comedy
tickets so you feel comfortable getting a real fucking car.
Speaking of which,
I'll be in San Francisco at the punchline.
January,
2016,
17,
18th,
19th.
Come get some free club.
That's why one of the great clubs in the country,
without a doubt,
the punchline at San Francisco is one of the tonic sites on earth.
We're Friday,
we're,
um,
tonight we're actually,
we're at the ice house.
Oh,
can I do a quick,
uh,
I'll go ahead.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
I just wanted to do a quick promo.
Thanks.
A iTunes for rating 10 minute podcast and the top three comedies of 2012.
It was really pumped and my leg Tourette's or something.
Why would you say that in the middle of someone's health saying something else
outside of that side.
I was saying,
I was asking me if I could promote with you,
but why would you do that?
Why would you do that?
When we're talking about the exact day of the show,
we're saying we've got a show tonight.
Can I just stop you?
I'm sorry.
I'll stop you right now and talk about my,
sorry.
That's a ridiculous thing to,
so I thought you was going to say something related that you had to get out.
No,
I was completely just turned it on yourself.
Sorry.
I was no reason to piggy back on.
I'm talking,
we have a show tonight.
You fuck show at the,
at the Ice House Comedy Club
in the small room.
It's Brian Red Ban,
not Brian Cowen.
Um,
uh,
Sam note.
Tripoli's.
Yeah,
it's incredibly cheap.
Uh,
Kevin Christie,
great.
All very cool people.
And it's like the most intimate room in La.
It's in Pasadena actually,
so set even in la,
but it's five minutes of that room.
That's it.
The little room only seats like 80 people.
It's a good place to fuck around and work out.
And so,
uh,
it's,
it's like one of the most fun places to come.
So it's tonight at 10 o'clock.
How much?
Uh,
15 bucks.
And it's the Ice House,
the Ice House,
which is like the greatest fucking club in the history of the San Fernando
Valley,
but it's not even in the San Fernando Valley.
It's in a different valley is actually,
what is it?
Bourbon?
No,
I don't think so.
Pasadena is not the San Fernando.
What is that?
Whatever it is.
It's right near Alta Dena figured out bitch.
It's on the way to big bear,
but that's tonight at 10:00 PM so a go home,
wash your pussy,
put on your favorite tee shirt.
It's a cold room because we all just kind of pretty much fuck around with new
material,
so it's not like a regular show where it's usually like sets.
It's a lot of fucking around so it's fun.
It's cool to watch.
Sorry to interrupt.
No,
I'm just fucking around this guy.
I love people and this guy just sent me a message.
Move on.
You're being a bitch to Brian Cowen.
Hey,
fuck you.
White Horse Captain White Night.
Thank you.
White horse.
I want to say your name,
dummy account.
It was so gross,
man.
They can't even take people fucking with you.
Go to stu who could
or go to say monitoring.
I'm going to talk now.
Neutral top when you're doing your jumping on each job.
I finally watched.
Hang
over to that was your role in that was really good.
Did you wait?
So are you in hangover three also?
I was offered a part in the hangover
three and I was doing a movie called ride along,
so I couldn't do it.
Let's be honest.
Hangover too.
As a fucking terrible movie.
It was really,
really bad.
I didn't do the whole thing.
I watched,
I paid for it.
I watched the whole thing and I'll say this,
this movie a ride along I did with Kevin Hart.
That guy's the funniest.
He kills me.
He fucking kills me.
I'm trying to do a scene with him.
Every single time he do something,
he'd do something that made me laugh.
He just does shit out of nowhere where you're just like this guy.
He's,
he's going to be something man.
He's already,
he's already,
he's,
and he's such a fucking good guy.
Do you know him?
Oh,
he's such a fucking good human being.
That's awesome.
Like he's just a,
Kevin Hart is a classic example of,
he's just a great human being,
man.
It's like the kind of person you are so happiest successful because he's such a
fucking great guy.
I,
I'm,
I'm being very traumatic.
But I really mean,
were you there during the taping at the same time that Brody got some kind of
like blow job from a man girl?
Well that never happened but I was there and I was telling them never happened.
I don't think so cause I was there.
And what it talks about,
he's a wine.
Oh maybe it wasn't when I was there,
but we were at the lady boy thing and I said to him,
I said,
Brody,
if you take that girl home,
even though it's a guy,
it does not make you gay because that's the best looking chick up ever.
So did he or didn't he?
He says he did.
Oh,
I don't mean he got,
he gets really emotional about it.
I Dunno.
You just weren't there with him the whole time.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are you saying all right,
wow.
Brody might be full shit.
Brody might be crazy.
No,
no,
I that's not something you'd want to lie about.
Yeah,
there's a good story.
If you suck,
I need a new 10 minutes.
And I wasn't,
I wasn't with them the whole time.
Just talking about deep sucking my Dick.
So a lot of dudes with stories about dude suck in their decks.
I think about Stan hope had a nice one.
That was a nice story about who else?
Like the fourth or noon of showing your Dick at a comedy club.
You know how like guys all show their dicks at the comedy clubs.
I think that's the next stage.
People don't know that,
but it's not all comedy clubs.
It's just the store.
Is that,
yeah.
I've never seen anybody's dick anywhere else.
Oh,
at the funny bone.
I saw a few,
few,
few Willie's in Columbia.
And think how gross that is.
You're at the funny button
in his mouth.
Exactly.
Um,
no.
In the comedy store,
I saw everybody pull their dick out,
but our,
he got in trouble for pulling his dick out in Hbo.
Like you can't just pull your dick out place.
People get really upset about that exposure yet.
But are you had a really funny bit where he pulled his dick out at the end,
dropped his pants and pulled his cock out.
Jim Norton's really funny.
He was for Jim Door Norton show.
Yeah.
But uh,
apparently he didn't tell them and he was going to do it this way.
I would say holding as he got a piece on him.
He's got giant balls.
It's Dixon normal.
I mean it would probably be impressive as balls were tiny.
If his balls were like little marbles,
he'd be like just the size of his cock.
His balls are preposterous.
Look,
Star Wars,
he somewhere in his family must have been a whole herd of sluts because uh,
the amount,
the size of a human's balls apparently are directly proportionate to the amount
of promiscuous females in,
in your,
in your area.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's why a humans and chimps have such giant nuts.
But gorillas have little tiny ones cause gorillas just run shit.
They have little dicks and they're giant.
So they'd get like a few bitches and they're like,
you get stay here.
I got Ya.
And then he fucks them.
But because there's no competition because there are so giant,
so dominant because there's no competition with like these women fucking other
men,
their ball stay little and their dicks a little.
But like champs,
you can't hold a chimp pitch and check.
Those bitches are freaks.
They're out there and the fucking trees banging dude's behind your back and,
and,
and bang and people and
say,
I was in uh,
uh,
Indonesia and I,
um,
I helped rehabilitate orangutans and advertise at the store.
Yeah,
you did.
we're orangutan adolescents will will rape.
We'll try to rape a female.
June women,
female.
You have to be careful around them cause I'll grab you and they'll pull your
pants.
Oh,
don't females in heat.
Won't they try to meet with males as well?
I don't know.
I saw,
I saw there was a lot of sexual activity cause I was around them constantly.
They were always like licking each other
and then,
and then fucking,
we watched one rape a that the older adolescents will,
will steal the little girls,
little kids and they'll,
they'll,
you know,
not humans,
but the orangutans that were like three or three and pull him up in a tree and
rape them.
And we watched one rape,
a fucking chicken,
uh,
under a,
under a house.
It was,
it was fucking a chicken masturbating and trying to fuck the chicken and the
cause of the hall.
It's when we were talking about crazy the other day that we're lucky that human
beings can't breed with other animals because if they did,
there would be a Schumann slash everything all over the world.
Monkeys,
giraffes,
zebras.
Right.
Did you ever see Hugh Manzi?
No.
You ever seen who,
yeah,
it's a documentary about a chimp that was a freak chimp that would walk on two
legs and looked like a hybrid and it terrified people because they thought for
the longest time before genetics,
we're really pull it up because it will freak people out.
For the longest time before they really got a grip on genetics.
They thought that these,
that this was a human chimpanzee hybrid.
You got to see its face.
That's not it.
That's crazy.
You guys see its face because it didn't have much hair on its face.
It looks that's not it.
It looked,
just pull up [inaudible] Z,
not chimp rapes a frog.
Fuck.
But they do that.
What?
Yeah,
no,
they do this.
That's a Humanz zy spell it right.
Fuck z e Humanz you like a chimpanzee but humanity
all over the champ.
Uh,
yes.
It was all over the chimp.
That was,
um,
that was what these,
uh,
this family,
look at it.
It's so creepy.
Look at it.
Walk Upright,
hangs out with people and was in love with this woman.
Look how weird it's faces.
There was something wrong with it genetically or say it had some variation,
but it was,
uh,
especially when it was young,
it really resembled a human being.
Look at him there.
As it got older,
it got more and more chimp like and got hairier boat when it was younger.
Um,
and apparently he was madly in love with the woman.
Uh,
and like that's when it became a problem.
Like he was trying to fuck the woman all the time.
Yeah.
Well I huge mail chimp is no joke man.
Well not only that,
they want pussy,
you know,
they want something like why you don't have any chimps around here for me,
they have moods flying or rages.
They get cold and they shit.
They have genetic like signals that are going off left and right that are trying
to give them the reward for breeding.
Like it's firing at full force and then you have no outlet for that.
That's just bananas.
That's completely crazy.
It's like what they do with tigers when they cage them and they wonder why they
pace back and forth and back and forth.
You're sliding a tray of meat under the door.
You're not giving it anything to kill.
Like this whole thing is designed to kill fee.
That's why,
that's why it moves so fast.
That's why it has giant claws.
It's can kill things.
So when it kills things,
it gets this orgasm like rush of endorphins in this reward from nature because
you're not just surviving.
You're doing what your program to do.
You're not like chasing these animals out of desperation.
You roll the fucking ball in front of a cat and I'll dive on it.
They're doing it for the thrill,
so he'd taken away all the thrill out of life just so you could stare at them.
Right.
I hate that.
That's why I don't like zoos.
I wonder if it would be a tiger human combo.
If a person could fuck a tiger,
they would figure out a cross Ponick DNA that's hold it down at fuck it.
I think what they would have to do is they would have to just net it.
It would be one dude who was a bad motherfucker.
Want him to tiger to carry his baby,
wanted to make like tiger people.
They thought that was like the next level and he would have to like,
don't have to like,
it would have to be like a whole village would be involved.
You'd have to get routed.
She can hide in the trees.
It's kind of weird.
You'd get it up if you're a freak.
Yeah.
I guess if you're in a fucking animals,
there's dudes are in a fucking animals.
Yeah.
So you'd have to like get the net dropped the net down like with giant boulders
and then everybody would have to move in somehow and you'd have to hold this
fucker down.
No uncomfortable.
Before they had like drugs to drug.
We don't want a drug.
The woman,
the woman tiger.
Because then with the baby's going to come out all fucked up.
Not only did half person,
it's retarded pans out.
Got some drugs that can maybe,
but this is Pfizer.
We're talking about two thousand three thousand years ago and you had to use
Carrari and shit yet a poison them and did like a half state of paralysis and
then stick your Dick in him.
I wonder,
I wonder if anybody's ever fucked a tiger of throughout human history there's
gotta be one dude.
No way to Tony last shot.
A tiger hasn't,
hasn't tried to at least one person.
Oh,
once it's dead,
that doesn't count.
That's not why you can't fuck tell you.
But everybody breeding and have to have to be in a breeding like they have for
pit bulls when they breed them that that they,
it's like a breeding mountain.
Yeah.
A back 'em
up into like some stocks contraption.
Yeah.
It's like a stock but people looking at that humanity,
you could clearly see why people would think that that was some sort of a
hybrid.
Yeah.
I mean that was it.
That is a for Riki looking thing.
When you see him it's so real and so human walking on two legs and he's walking
around and he's just hanging out with people and he's got that weird hairless
phase.
Nobody questioned it.
Nobody was like,
it's impossible.
No one would fuck a chimp.
They immediately thought somebody fucked a chimp.
It was like right away.
Cause they know what our capabilities is that a woman in Connecticut who lost
her face,
that owner would take baths with that champ and drink wine at a long stemmed
glasses.
She was running it.
She left that shelf fucker.
Yeah,
I think so.
And I think that's why the other chimp killed that bitch because that chick
probably tried to cock block.
She's probably cock blocking.
She changed her hair that day.
She had her hair done and she came and the chimp,
that's all was well,
it's a fucking mail.
200 pound fucking adult chimp.
So guess what it's called?
The very dangerous wild animal.
My Buddy Kirin's a stunt man goes,
the only thing I don't think I said,
what's scariest dining goes anything with chimpanzees.
I don't mess with them.
That's what he said.
It does everything.
Fighting,
falling motorcycles.
A chance.
Yeah,
Dude.
Fuck all that.
They grab a hold of you.
You know you're going to lose a knows at least before somebody gets to you and
cheer.
Chances are you're going to lose half your face or your balls or your balls or
your Dick.
You know,
we were talking earlier about a new Guinea.
Yeah.
Um,
if you ever heard of those,
uh,
those tribes,
the believe that the young boys have to ingest semen.
Yes.
How do you know how prevalent that is?
It's also in the islands.
What does it where they,
it's called widow strangling where a,
if your husband dies,
they strangle the widow and she'll cough to her brothers to do it if her
brothers aren't around her son.
Does it?
Yeah,
I think it's the Solomon Islands or the governor islands or something out in,
out in like,
uh,
like near pop out and Guinea or something.
What's the point in that wire?
This triangle.
Her fucking,
it's a very isolated culture where some psycho came out with an idea and people
took it as tradition and they would do it.
It's dumb shit because when you've got us to a group of people that have had no
contact with the outside world for Millennia,
you get these really weird,
a strange customs that will actually stick and they can be as crazy as widows
strangling,
by the way,
what is it in,
in,
in India before when w w w but God and the turn of the century where,
where,
um,
if a woman was,
if her husband was dead,
she would be burned.
What was it called?
Um,
as a sort of a sacrifice.
Uh,
it's called fuck what is all like Viking style.
They'd throw them on the,
she'd be on a pile of wood and they would,
and she would burn and they would burn her.
Um,
I know all,
no offense to anybody who's Indian.
It was a,
it was a Hindu tradition,
I think it was.
It was,
and I can't remember what it was,
but there's a word for it.
It was practiced commonly,
uh,
in
certain parts of India.
And all I'm saying is that in every culture has very,
very sort of rather dreadful ideas of,
of what they call culture.
Uh,
it's just Danny,
we evolve as human beings.
It's amazing.
When the Soviets got to Afghanistan,
they s when a girl was born,
a lot of times there was no time or use for a girl in that,
in that village.
And they would just throw them off cliffs,
the infants,
they would throw them off,
throw them off class.
And that's one of the things is Soviet said.
They were like,
this is fucking nuts.
Those,
those,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
look at the,
what just happened.
They visit videotape going all over the world.
The Afghan tribe where the,
the woman who is considered a beautiful girl,
everybody liked her.
She was married,
some Taliban commander captures her,
takes her off,
rapes her and apparently somebody else to as well.
They had a big meeting.
They went and rescued her.
These,
his,
they've got the husband's friends,
they killed the guy.
They brought the girl back.
They decided she had to marry the guys that she was one of our attackers or she
probably committed adultery,
so we're going to shoot her.
So the husband took a machine gun and shot her about six times.
Her family came collecting the body and that's how you did it.
And that's how you do it still in certain parts of Afghanistan and those
backward,
um,
villages,
human beings have always done when they're ignorant and they're not exposed to
the right way of doing things.
They've always done things like that.
And they still do things like amazing that it coexists with the Internet,
the coexists with the good watching the history channel.
But it's going on at the same time.
Well,
but the great thing is in this gang rape in India that everybody's talking
about.
What happened was gang rapes in India.
I've been going on forever and the cops never really persecute,
prosecute him and the cops look very bad.
When this woman was raped with her friend,
they they and assaulted with a metal bar.
She was bleeding so badly.
They threw them out naked out of the car.
It took 25 minutes before the cops came.
The cops then argued for 40 minutes about who had jurisdiction.
The cost didn't want to touch her because she was bleeding too much to the
friend had to put her in there.
They get to the hospital.
They still had to wait in the waiting room and then of course she died,
but this is not an uncommon thing.
What happened when that word got out in India for the first time was young
college students started tweeting and organizing mass rallies saying this has
been going on for way too fucking long.
It's always been you.
You'd get a choice.
Another girl in India who was raped there.
There was a choice.
This is in the lower,
this is the,
this is people who are not as educated,
but the girl had a choice.
Mary,
your attacker,
one of your attackers or don't press charges.
It was a,
you know,
somehow the woman is to blame and what's happening in,
in these societies and all these studies is they're modernizing like you said,
because they have access to information.
Young people who are educated and going,
this is bullshit.
This makes our country look terrible.
This is unacceptable.
It's been going on too long.
And that's one of the great things about,
about the internet.
I think it's one of the greatest things about the,
what is it about people that allows them to do something like a gang
rape?
How does that happen?
Well,
they said that one of the young guys who was raping was reaching into her body
and pulling out her intestines.
There you go with his hand.
There you go.
I mean,
that's fucking unbelievably evil.
It's unbelievable evil.
It's,
it's been going on.
That's what men do when they get in groups.
And they're fucking sociopath's are in a gang.
When you get that many of us together though to that crazy you,
you come from a,
you come,
and I'm not saying it's Indian culture.
You come from a part of the world,
uh,
whether it's your village or whether it's your family,
where,
where women are treated as chattel or dogs or less than human.
And that's what happens.
That's,
that's why we have examples of that from the beginning of time.
It's just amazing.
That can discuss,
cultures can degrade to that point that somehow or another you can get to the
point where you can have gang rapes on a regular basis.
It's a common thing,
you know,
or this new Guinea thing like that.
I mean,
it's
just,
it's even more crazy than gang rape.
There are countless examples of that.
You know,
it's a problem.
So it's not because it's like,
I guess,
I dunno.
It's,
it's crazy.
They're both great problem with male dominated societies.
Actually,
if you look at male patriarchal societies,
Eh,
the problem with them is that they tend to be,
um,
they will always keep women in,
in a certain place.
And if women try to get out of that place of the problem is solved a lot of
times with violence.
But I've also been thinking,
and I don't have the data on this,
but matriarchal pat,
patriarchal societies,
societies dominated by men usually are always at war with either someone or
themselves.
There's a lot of violence in society.
What society isn't states,
I think for the most part is,
is if come comparison is a country that at least has dialogue about equal
rights,
glass ceilings,
women are in positions of power have been for a long time.
They were given,
the vote wasn't 1934 with the suffragette movement.
Right.
But,
but,
but that's,
that's,
that's always been,
that's Europe for that matter.
The liberal democracy still.
I would say there was,
there's still an inequality if you just looked at it on paper as far as wealth,
prestige,
power,
influence between men and women are the important things that we're talking
about it.
The important thing is that there is a,
there's the people know what's right versus what's wrong.
You know why we're talking about it?
The Internet?
No,
we don't have prostitution.
If we had legalized prostitution,
we would just like,
God damn it.
Why are we arguing about this shit?
Jesus Christ.
Why am I'm arguing?
I'm trying to make you happy.
So I sold my little sucks.
Junkie Island.
It's a girl who wants help with their rent.
That's all it is.
Isn't prostitution,
legal and Rhode Island?
I don't think so.
Somebody told me yesterday.
No,
no,
I don't.
I May.
It's a new law.
I don't think so.
Why don't you Google it?
I know that it's legal in Carson city or not Carson city,
Nevada.
Uh,
I think it's Clark County.
One of those counties,
but it's not the Vegas County,
oddly enough.
It's out in the middle of dry.
Yeah.
Like when we went to the Bunny ranch,
we filmed a,
some we,
we went to the bunny ranch when I was doing the man show and I played pretty
women for them and we,
uh,
had them all like a talk about the scenes in pretty woman and like what the
scene meant to them.
And
Dude,
it was legal up to 2009.
Really.
And can you imagine they just lost like,
the best thing and we just found about in Rhode Island was legal plants.
What's wrong with you,
Rhode Island?
I know that.
Why isn't that the best spring break place?
I was really aren't 2008.
What the fuck?
Nobody even told me Shit.
Probably Porn Stars who have to turn tricks a lot more now because they're not
making as much money making movies.
I heard a girl describing that in the interview.
She's at a,
uh,
one of the girls to do porn and now she was at the bunny ranch and they were
talking about,
um,
like that too.
A lot of them.
It's no different that she said it's porn is just like one big brothel.
It's just they film it this way.
It's like you're doing the same thing,
but we don't film it like those guys aren't my boyfriend that I'm having sex
with.
So that was her justification of it.
It's really,
it was really strange to read cause she was talking about her boyfriend that she
lives with and that for someone like that,
they were asked her,
do you do overnights because I guess overnights or like went up a hooker stays
the whole night and he just mauler all that.
She goes,
well it would have to be a lot of money to keep me away from the man that I love
Jesus.
And I'm like,
whoa.
Wow.
Like what kind of,
wow,
what?
What an odd place today.
That's a strange thinking.
Unusual thinking.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if that you were that guy and you just sitting at home because
you're a lazy fuck you.
You don't have a job.
Your girlfriend's mouth everywhere.
Her ass,
her mouth.
The guy's paying like five grand.
He's raw dog in her face,
you know,
you know?
Yes.
Yeah.
She's sucking as balls while he's jerking off looking in her eyes.
I just don't want to make out with you after that.
Yeah,
well you know,
there's nothing wrong with it if he likes it and she likes it,
but if you're,
you know,
some people get off on it and trying to pretend that you'll just working,
she ain't just working,
she's getting paid to do something that you know,
a lot of people do for free.
It's a weird thing when you're,
you're,
you were agreeing to have sex with someone that you don't want to have sex with
and you're doing it over money or she does want to just a re look,
there's nothing wrong with it.
There's nothing wrong with it,
but there's a reason why it's looked upon.
Weirdly,
it's because it does sort of bypass the whole social system that's in place
that's Sorta,
Kinda designed to make people be nice to each other.
Like the reason why sex is like people like having sex with you so they like
you.
They,
like you said,
it gives you incentive to be nice to them,
to be a person that they want to be around.
They want to give you affection,
you want to give them affection.
It becomes mutual.
And then for some people it's just like,
I don't have time for that.
I give you some money and then I fucking treat you like shit and spit in your
mouth.
And like
it's Rhode Island place by the way,
is my new destination.
When time travel it becomes illegal because now it's also,
you could be 16 to be like a stripper or a prostitute.
Back in 2009 that was the age of consent was 16 so there's all these 16 year old
hookers in Rhode Island and none of us knew about Rhode Island.
2009 for some reason
dark.
I couldn't do that because I'd have to.
I don't want any,
she keep her secret.
That's too fucked up,
man.
No,
not 16 I was a weird place.
I used to do a lot of gigs in Rhode Island,
which is super small or what's the dude?
Yeah,
it's tiny.
I think it's the tiniest state in the union.
It's um,
is it?
Yeah,
it's really,
it's really little man.
He could drive through in a couple of hours.
I did a lot of gigs.
There isn't [inaudible] Rhode Island where Whitey Bulger ran the underground?
No,
no.
South Boston.
Yeah.
That crazy balls or ran the underground and his brother was the mayor.
Not only,
no,
no.
His brother was,
uh,
some,
some other big time politician,
but more importantly,
he was an FBI informant the entire time.
So he was ratting out all these other bad people and then getting them killed.
Like if they would turn on him,
like we would say,
yeah,
they would say,
hey,
this guy's about to testify against Ya.
And they could kill them.
Like the FBI would warn him so that he would keep,
like,
he would keep giving them people to arrest,
you know,
so they would,
they would,
they were in business together and the FBI would look the other way if he was
selling drugs or if he was doing certain things,
even murder.
They look the other way with for murder.
It's really unbelievably fucked up.
When you look at the whole story about how complicit the FBI was really a movie
about that.
I mean the departed was sort of a,
an artistic rendition rendition of it.
It wasn't really accurate there.
They had some artistic license they use,
but it was sort of,
uh,
a lot of it was on the Lam for like 30 years in Santa Monica,
man,
Sam's living in Santa Monica.
And they found him because of his wife,
his wife or his girlfriend,
mouthy bitch saying,
I went,
it was,
you know,
they fight and yell and scream at each other apparently.
And people,
people were looking into them because of that,
because they would like violently yell at each other.
Yeah.
And apparently he would like he'd,
he'd be,
they'd be talking and then all of a sudden I didn't know where he'd go.
All right,
let's go.
Come on,
let's get out of here.
I'm tired of this.
Like he would just fly off the handle.
Well,
he probably was really bored.
The guy ran a crime empire forever and then all of a sudden he's hanging out
with some crazy bitch in an apartment and you know,
you got to pretend to be Sam Smith and hammer or whatever the fuck you are now.
I think a lot of criminals.
That's true.
That's like the biggest thing is the juice.
Yeah.
I should have went to Mexico.
Shit,
I'm like gangster dawn till dusk style.
You know,
watched his Santa Monica,
they'll let you in to Mexico.
Nice.
Come on son.
Get out of here.
You got to go to Mexico.
Should have gone to Mexico.
Get a nice place near Cabo.
Blend right in and get a Tan.
Shave your head.
Let me know what the fuck you are.
It's true
medical marijuana and Rhode Island from starting at 2006 to 2006 to 2009.
And it's meet there when
time machines are,
has got the first clubs,
right.
Pot Clubs,
now they're about to open one,
but it doesn't say anything about smoking pot in public place.
The law does not allow that.
And so I suppose kind of building the place that you've seen in your own home.
Yeah,
you can at bars,
but they don't have licenses for like,
it's a situation.
So what it's going to be as like you're gonna have to get a membership.
That's how they do in certain states.
They have a that with booze.
There was certain states,
it wasn't Utah,
it wasn't just Utah.
Where was it?
North Carolina,
maybe I forget,
but it was back in the day,
you had to uh,
go to a club.
There were certain clubs like after a certain time at night and you could go
there,
but you had to pay for a membership.
Like they had a like cigars and I think one of them even had strippers and he
had to like be a member.
You had to like pay because there's laws.
So the way to get around the laws to make it private,
so I'll,
everybody becomes a member,
they'll go there and give your id,
fill out your name and your address and give him 20 bucks to whatever the fuck
it is.
A guy gives you a key.
Now you remember,
it's like silly.
It's silly of shit ever.
But that's the only way to do it,
right?
They had to like skirt around the law.
So what they're gonna do with this Colorado thing isn't going to make it so that
you,
you know,
you're a member and you'd go there and then you could all smoke weed together,
but someone's going to fuck that up.
The real problem with it is that it's only two states and it's not federal yet.
I hope this is the beginning,
but I hope that it's not fuel for blow back.
I hope that they don't fuck it up somehow.
And you also have to be careful of um,
agent provocateurs and all sorts of different people that are going to try to,
if the DEA was smart and they wanted to keep that business going.
And I know that there's people in the DEA,
they're smart and I know there's people in Dea,
they want to keep that business going.
One of the things they do is they influence raise,
they go into the business of arresting people for selling drugs.
As soon as drugs become legal,
there's a whole lot less jobs for DEA people.
So that's what the lobby's about.
That's what the Tasco a whole lot less people in jail,
prison guard lobby also lobbied very hard to make sure that people don't make
drugs illegal.
But one of the things that um,
undercover cops and undercover DEA guys have done,
it's forced people to buy and sell much more than they really needed.
Like they,
there's a guy that's in jail,
there was a big article about it and Rolling Stone magazine and a,
this DEA guy was undercover,
turned out to be a junkie himself when he went to rehab after he quit.
The force and it was,
was a actually a discharge.
He was fired because of impropriety.
Um,
set this guy up and asked this guy to,
uh,
to get him some weed and gave him some money for it and then said,
listen man,
um,
you know,
I can get you,
$100,000 if you can get me some coke and you know,
I need this amount of weed and this amount of coke.
And the guy's like,
I can't do that.
He goes,
look,
I'll set you up with the people.
It's cool man.
Trust me.
I just need you to like,
you know,
dot all the i's and cross all the t's and,
and you're going to make all this money.
So he literally set up the whole fakes and trap.
Yeah.
It's complete.
Total in and not only out of the guy was like 19 years old.
So dumb young.
Yeah.
It would've been the sound of a hundred grand.
I mean,
living in the south,
that easy,
uneducated,
dumb young living in Georgia and this guy gets off on sending him to jail.
He's in jail for the rest of his life.
He's in jail for the rest of his life and he was just a young kid that was,
he thought I was going to sell a dude who had already sold weed to started to
sell him some more weed.
Hey man,
you made the world safe for,
yeah.
It's unbelievable how they can sort of just rope kids in and,
and they do it like you.
How could you do that to a teenager?
I mean,
how could you pretend that you're doing,
you're serving and protecting.
How can you pretend that you're doing anything that's like trying to keep people
safe?
You're just like,
you found a hole through the system and it hasn't been homemade.
Illegal.
Yeah.
It's a hard case.
I hope that's a,
Ah,
I hope that's a rare case that you're talking.
I hope it is too,
but I don't think it is.
I think it's a,
I think it's pretty common that people get set up.
I think it's pretty fucking family.
I think if they find out you're,
you're growing and selling large amounts of blow your,
your,
your fucking,
it's not just that.
There was a kid who was arrested in Florida.
He was 17 years old.
He's an honor roll student.
He was arrested by an undercover cop who pretended to be his girlfriend.
I remember that dude.
Yeah,
she's 25 years old and hot.
Okay.
Hot this dirty Twat.
She got close to this kid and he wanted to give her or the weed for free as a
gift because she asked him to get her weed.
He wanted to give it to her for free.
Like I got it for you.
She's like,
no,
you got to have the money.
Please take the money.
So he takes the money.
Boom.
He's arrested.
He's a sociopath.
She's a raging cunt and she thought she was just doing her job.
She's doing her job.
He's an honor roll student.
Okay.
No weed in his system.
He wasn't a drug dealer in any way,
shape or form.
He just met a girl and he was in love with her Wa and one of the reasons why
he's in love with it because he probably understood that she was a woman.
It probably was confusing and 17 a 25 year old,
that's the,
that's the holy grail.
You'll do anything.
He didn't know she was 25 my pinky off,
he whatever.
He didn't know she was 25 but she was so teasing him,
teasing him.
She was so powerful.
That's the,
the amount of influence that a 25 year old.
Yeah,
the amount of influence.
25 year old woman has over 17 year old boy is fucking staggering.
I mean that's like,
she's like a wizard.
Of course she got this poor fucking kid to go.
She was kind of a backlash,
wasn't there?
How about that?
Oh yes,
of course.
But nobody got arrested.
Nobody wants their job.
It was called Operation d d minus or something like that.
Something stupid dumb cunts.
21 jump street.
Some fucking bullshit.
So stupid man.
It's the idea that you,
your tax dollars,
Mexico.
Now it's dealing with the violence of the drugs.
Think it's the underwritten laws.
Look,
you can,
you can sell drugs,
stop fucking cutting heads off and leaving them in squares because it's illegal.
So it means the same thing that happened in the 1920s with alcohol.
Fuck is it legal?
It's going to
track those kinds of people,
those kinds of people that are willing to kill.
Like you know anybody they have to.
Do you watch uh,
that um,
uh,
boardwalk empire?
No,
I haven't watched it yet.
Good show.
I'm,
I'm obsessed right now and watching,
uh,
I'm on my fourth season of breaking bad and that's,
that's a mindblowing show to me.
It's a mind blowing show,
you know,
it's just as good homeland.
I hear,
oh I've seen five episodes.
I'm waiting to watch it.
That's my next Claire Danes is a bad ass bitch.
She is fucking bad ass.
Yeah.
That chicken act or fucking ass off.
She might be the best female actor on the planet earth.
Really?
Well I would say I'm glad I got my money on that crazy bitch.
Especially if she's playing crazy dude.
She gets an a plus five star Tommy.
Cause that's my next dude.
That's my next thing.
She is fucking some bad ass.
Great TV out there.
There is now.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going on.
Why is there so much good stuff?
I think because movies are so impossible to make.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
You can't get money for them.
They went and you can never get the actor you want.
You can't get the,
you can't do anything except that it's,
it's corporate,
you know,
but the money speaks and that's what counts.
And so you want to,
you want to do a movie and they have this great actress in mind like Claire
Danes and they go,
no,
it has to be Heather Graham cause she's popular overseas.
And you're like,
what the fuck am I doing?
So all the talent has moved to TV.
People are like,
I'm going to make TV.
Fuck,
fuck film.
It's also when you do a film,
you've got to go somewhere for six months and it's sucks.
At least if you're doing a TV show and then you know,
nobody will watch you get one shot and the bad reviews,
you're fucked.
Right?
If you're doing a TV show,
you can film it somewhere.
You go somewhere and yet you get a house there and you're,
you know,
maybe this is your new place where you live,
but at least you can have a home.
Right?
These people that like,
like Kevin James,
I talked to him,
he's like six months in one hotel,
six months in another hotel.
His stays in the hotels for months.
Yeah.
Fuck,
I just did it.
I was just,
and at the lowest and Atlanta Blah.
It's not,
it's not fun.
Even if you're staying in a suite and it's never,
yeah,
I don't mind.
Like when I do gigs on the road,
I stay in a hotel for a weekend and I go back home.
That's fine.
That's,
that's easy.
But that's six months.
Shit,
that shit's for the birds.
You know,
people don't realize that.
A weird lifestyle that the acting,
I always say people saw how I show at movies are really made people magazine,
US magazine.
And I'll be out of business cause it's not as glamorous.
It's the,
it's you're literally shooting a page a day maybe,
which means you're doing the same thing over and over again.
And it's just not,
well,
if it's a great movie though,
it's really fun.
Like even like,
which wasn't a great movie,
but the movie's zookeeper that it did little kids moving.
Yeah,
Kevin.
It was fun because I like Kevin,
he's fun and there was a fun movie to do.
It was fun.
We were sitting here around Comedians by the way.
It's great,
but also be around a bunch of act like my,
one of the guys that did the movie with,
uh,
I didn't tell you this,
one of the guys,
I want to say his name and I did a movie with a riding along.
He had just been in Lincoln with Dan Day Lewis on that set.
Daniel Day Lewis,
he spoke to Daniel Day Lewis,
you know,
when he talked to them about current events in 1865.
Okay.
That's everyone referred to him as mister president.
So he was completely in character.
Ah.
And that that whole,
that whole place,
dude,
current events set was quiet unless it,
Spielberg was talking to the actor.
It was quiet.
From what I keep it,
you can keep your wig,
your character and your fucking movie.
I got no fucking,
I got no attention span anyway so I would have been fired immediately cause I
would have been fucking around the whole time.
I'm not an acting,
I just want to hang out and get paid and be a silly goose.
You don't want to do like serious work by the way.
I had,
I had such a good time in this thing.
But you know,
ice cube,
he's a great guy.
Laurence Fishburne who happens to be a fan of yours.
I did.
I tell you this,
the series here.
Um,
yeah,
that was cool.
It was good.
Then I got to,
I got to eat dinner with Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Yeah,
you told me that.
That seems pretty straight.
I was with John Leguizamo and he goes,
just stick around.
Someone's coming on.
He comes back with his assistant,
sits down,
has a little cup of butternut squash soup and I talked to him about California
politics.
No,
he's doing another version of Conan.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's going to do Kona.
And again,
old cone.
An old cone in,
see there was Robert E.
Howard,
the guy who wrote Conan wrote Conan through his whole life.
He wrote code man.
No,
I mean Conan rope Conan's life from a young man to an old king.
So he's going to do the old king version and he's going to uh,
go and,
um,
you know,
and play Kona and towards the end,
because that was like in like a lot of the older books,
some of the best books.
In fact,
some of the,
uh,
not the older books,
the more recent books before he ended it,
ended it in his thirties.
Um,
but he,
he had written about Kona and as being,
you know,
a king sitting on the phone and forced back into action again,
I believes in his sixties.
Yep.
I remember,
I remember that.
I read every book that he ever,
every single book.
Robert Howard ever.
Yeah,
I wrote a lot.
I read a lot of his stuff.
The crawl,
the conqueror and all that other shit too.
Surfer.
Yeah.
He
was actually amazing books because especially the way they would open,
you just have this description of this,
this giant with smoldering blue,
volcanic blue eyes,
just cutting a path of crimson through all these sort of,
these,
these orcs or whatever.
And then he would just stand there and wait.
There was one survivor and he would stand there and he looked up at the,
that the giant with,
with his,
his black dreaded hair just covered in blood,
dreaded in his eyes.
And he's like,
who are you?
And you just hear,
he'd always answer the same way.
He'd go,
I am calling in some area.
You're like,
oh,
leave.
The writing was really good.
Oh it was the first time I ever read something.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
And I just had to disappointment in my life that I,
I'm five 11 one 70 well that's cause you don't do anything about it.
I fucking lift.
I lift weights.
I've worked out with you and I,
there's a level
of intensity that you need to come to.
You kidding me?
Anybody want to touch this interesting thing about Robert Howard?
Is he like,
he like stayed at home.
It was kind of a shut in.
He was like a really weird guy.
He was also a sickly guy.
What,
that's why I wrote about this guy who was invincible.
This guy with insane genetics.
We just cut people down with swords,
muscularity and stuff.
Did you ever see the Vincent D'onofrio movie where he played robbery?
Howard?
No.
Yeah,
I forgot what it's called.
I never saw it,
um,
off.
I'll look it up right now.
Um,
but uh,
apparently it's pretty good.
A lot of people don't know who Robert Howard is.
This is really kind of interesting.
Well,
you know,
Carmen,
the uh,
the new Conan,
the guy looked really good.
He looked like he was a pretty good Cohen,
but the movie suck the fat one and it's too bad because the,
the whole wide world is the name of the movie.
He really does look at that guy's ass Samoan.
He's a,
I've met him a couple times.
Um,
used to wine.
Is He?
Yeah,
a lot.
A lot of Polynesians and he's a big striking guy,
man.
Yeah.
He's just like,
he's just fucking like,
you're like Jesus.
He looks like he does look like a cartoon character.
He came to the UFC.
I'm way back before Conan came out because of the UFC was sponsoring the movie
and a or the movie rather.
We're sponsoring that you have to say.
So we interviewed him and shit.
It was like a legit giant hops.
Six foot five.
How about Cain Velasquez?
I was incredible.
Incredible fight.
My Buddy Karen said to me before the fight,
he goes,
I said,
what's going to happen?
He goes,
I think Keynes gonna Maul him and he's not going to have a chance to breathe
out.
So what do you mean?
Cause he put his head in his chest and he's going to be,
he's just going to put a wrestling pace on him and he's going to beat the shit
out of him.
He's not going to step back and reset.
That's not what I tell him.
Sure enough,
I just watching someone who's as good and powerful as junior dos Santos get get
picked up and thrown on the ground by that guy.
Well he caught them.
The big thing was um,
not just the wrestling cause he wrestled around and put them down.
But yeah,
he cracked him when he cracked him with that right hand.
He heard him bad and he was never the same again.
He never could recover.
His endurance never recovered.
It says a lot about junior dos Santos though to be able to keep coming back
anyway and keep fighting like such as what,
what a stud.
His heart's amazing.
He just got,
when you get people don't understand like oh he was out of shape.
Like you don't know when you get hit it removes like all your endurance.
Like there's,
there's something crazy that happens to you when you get rocked.
It's like you want to call up and die.
You could be training for six months,
you could get up every morning and eat blueberries and run sprints up hills.
But when somebody punches you in the face,
you,
but that's right.
It's because your system is in full panic mode.
You just got hit with a piston,
you know,
from a 240 pound Mexican blam.
I mean he just uncorked that shit on your chin.
Your legs went wobbly.
Sparks went through your brain.
You're barely conscious right now.
Barely conscious.
So when he picks you up and dumps you,
when you're back,
now you lost even more consciousness.
You're barely hanging on.
He's just thumping you in the fucking head.
So at the end of the round when the bell ends and you get up like your,
he was barely there,
had come on and take some much.
Yeah,
you got cracked with a couple big punches and I was so impressed that he was
still there for the fifth rounds.
So many guys would have found a way out.
So many guys would have just curl up.
So much character and courage to stay in there with that guy.
And he started to get a second wind.
We're on the fourth and fifth rounds.
He started getting second when he was starting to throw some dangerous punches.
They didn't really connect clean.
But man,
if they did it could have changed a lot of shit.
He's so he threw a couple of laptops.
I was like,
God damn of one of those hits we might see a totally different fight.
That's right.
That's happened.
We've seen that.
Mick Brennan,
Shawn's last fight,
Brendan shops,
last fight.
He was um,
think it was his last fight where he was um,
finding big Ben Rothwell and he cracked big Ben Rothwell and they were in,
they were in a gunfight and all saw,
boom.
Rothwell uncorked is fucking big left hook and he's down.
Like you can happen that suddenly,
especially with heavyweights.
Well cause heavyweights have the same kind of head.
I mean,
you know,
Brendan's head isn't that big.
I always tease him because he's head is normal size to his huge body.
I sent him a video the other day,
I was like Ben and listen,
I came in when I said,
but,
but I'll actually see him tonight.
But he,
but you know when he's had six,
five to 50 and just in sick athlete.
But you know,
when you get hit with a head,
your head can only take so much off.
250 pound man who knows how to punch connects with your jaw.
I don't give a shit who you are.
Did you see your Fabio Maldonado versus Glover to share?
Did you see that felt [inaudible] it was in Brazil maybe four or five months
ago.
Anyway,
Fabio Maldonado is getting mauled Glover to shares off fucking savage.
He's beaten the shit out of Fabio.
I mean,
his face is bloody and swollen.
Takes him down,
smashing them.
I mean,
it's just unbelievable.
Heart by Fabio for surviving Glover's destroying them.
Glover in the next round he fucks around and drops his hands and it looks like,
it looks like Fabio is just a dead man.
Fabio uncork says,
left talking,
catches him perfect on the chin.
Glover's legs go like rubber and he's like Recia for to hang on.
It's like,
whoa.
Like the fight completely changed with one punch.
Yeah,
that can happen.
First of all,
you're not wearing gloves basically.
You're really not wearing gloves and I'm not a punch like that.
One mistake.
One error.
That's why MMA to me is so fascinating.
That's why I just love watching it so much.
Well,
did you ever see the Mike Russell Todd Duffy fine?
Um,
I don't think so.
Greatest One punch comeback in the history of sports.
No doubt about it.
Todd Duffy is built like a dude who was created in a lab.
I mean,
he's unbelievably athletic.
Just come up.
Let me see.
Just a ridiculous physical specimen.
I mean Todd Duffy's though fucking stud.
Okay.
And he is fighting this Guy Mike Russo,
who's a cop,
a Chicago cop,
active duty cop.
Okay.
Maybe one of the toughest human beings on the planet because Todd is hitting
this motherfucker with everything but the kitchen sink and you're talking about
Todd who was a 240 pounds shredded man and he moves like a cat and he is on
Corkin bombs on Russel,
right.
For three rounds.
This goes on and somehow another Russel survives with a broken arm.
This is the Kakais.
Yeah.
His left arm is broken and he hits Mike de hits,
Todd Duffy with one punch and drop some Qaddafi's unconscious with one punch
fall.
Look at Duffy follows up and changed,
drops a hammer fist on him with his broken hand.
The shame about his body.
I mean,
why don't you share the American man from Atlantis,
Patrick then?
Is that his cousin?
You saw a bald spot in my head,
I just,
hello?
Yeah,
he's gigantic man.
He's so this,
this,
this guy and in middle of nowhere and corks is one punch and turns the whole
fight around like that that can happen in any other sport.
And that's right when we look at his chin,
that dude looks like he takes a vicious beating.
So the fact that that can happen in the third round,
even when the guy was built like that,
he just one with Todd Duffy,
just one.
He um,
he looked fucking sensational.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He fought it out and he's been good for a while.
I've seen the kid fight a couple of times.
He fought.
Um,
uh,
this dude filled the Freese who's a really good Jujitsu guy and he,
he knocked him out.
He looked awesome.
It's amazing how the first fight back off.
See,
it's amazing how it's all so much evolved.
It's that you cannot just be a Jujitsu guy.
You can't just be a boxer.
You got to be everything.
Yeah.
There's not a lot of room for a one dimensional fighter always changing.
I was thinking about Jon Jones and Jon Jones has got to worry about Cain
Valasquez eventually.
Right.
I mean,
that's the fight for me.
That's the fight.
Well,
I think cane,
um,
and um,
Daniel Cormier as well because core Mba is going to probably wind up going down
to two o five,
call me a is a one had heavyweight one the strike force Grand Prix beat Josh
Barnett,
which is gigantic.
All this me as he long,
no,
it's short,
right?
I think he's five 11.
Hard to fight when you're five 11 fight and Jon Jones,
I don't know,
man.
That's,
it's very difficult to fight 82 in charms.
Well,
he definitely has a nice advantage.
It's not just John Jones,
his arms,
his legs,
and I always talk about like this,
this reach thing that we do.
We will measure the reach,
but we took it from boxing.
We need to incorporate like leg length,
fuck,
because like a guy like John,
a big part of his game is kicking you and he kicks you from a place where you
can't even touch,
especially when he's pushed kicking and doing those like sidekicks,
they hurt and he throws that sidekick to the thigh end of the body and he fucked
Vitara up with that thing.
Right?
He dropped him to the body with that.
Yeah.
That's a hard guy to get up.
But Cormier is a monster.
If he can be healthy and strong at two oh five,
first of all,
he's wrestling world fucking class.
I mean,
he was in the Olympics,
he had to,
but he had an issue where he,
uh,
tried to cut weight incorrectly to,
um,
to rest.
I think I wrestled at two oh six.
And,
uh,
he had kidney failure,
so he's gotta be real careful about the way it cuts.
If he's going to go down to a five it's gotta be a legit lifestyle change.
It can't be him getting silly and you know,
and trying to like dehydrated 40 pounds in two.
And Yeah,
with a lot of guys
do that,
man.
A lot of guys do that and they are,
they are really rolling ground or whatever.
I mean,
that guy does it.
He walks around at one 90 or something.
Right.
He's big.
He's a big thick,
muscular dude.
You know,
there's a lot of those cowboy,
I'm sorry I haven't talked to her at school,
but at Cabo was probably when I saw him at one point he was one 91 or something
like that.
He sucks down to 55 he's a big dude.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's tall and long too,
you know,
but he makes it no problem.
And he can go for three rounds hard at 55 so he's not,
whatever he's doing,
he can,
you know,
he can keep doing that.
It's like Benson Henderson,
same thing.
The champ,
he loses quite a bit of weight as well,
but he's very healthy and disciplined and now he does it.
So the results are,
you know,
when,
when he's actually in the octagon,
he can go five rounds.
No problem.
By the way,
I guess what I'm having on my podcast who?
Sugar Ray Leonard.
Ooh,
that's interesting.
Brian Callen show.
Thank you Joe or Brian Challenge and not,
not,
not man thoughts anymore.
It's called,
it's called fucking the Brian Council.
I was like,
you know what,
this man thought things.
It's not that sustainable.
I'm not really having me.
I said a fucking weird,
and it was given to me by my all,
I love my manager,
but I was like,
I don't know.
It's just a little too contrived.
I can't be contrived.
It's gotta be just Brian Collins can't ever listen to your managers when they
told him he's kind of shit,
but you need to tell you a creative things.
You've got to go.
Thanks.
Sit well with me where I feel like I'm trying to pull one over on.
I'm fans like where I'm like,
it's called man thoughts.
I'll be able to brand it.
I'll be able to have my t shirts.
It will be the men's store man thoughts class.
What did you,
we'll call it before that.
And you call it something else to Bryan County jail for that.
Nope.
Sorry.
I called you and I was like,
maybe I should call it the questions with Brian Cow.
And you're like,
and I was trying to come up with a format for it,
but I've been having fun just having conversations.
I keep the 20 hours,
the skeptic tank.
I'm like,
what is the,
you're not really,
I don't know,
cause I'm not,
I wish I was specific.
I'm too fucking all over the place,
but I'm,
I'm excited about.
What do you think I should ask?
Sure.
Ray.
I got a lot of questions.
Just talk to them.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
What's your favorite bubble gum?
What's his,
what's his toughest fight?
You know,
you'll,
you'll have some good conversations with them,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
don't worry about it.
But,
but the good thing is that you're all over the place.
That's a good thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
it makes these conversations so varied.
That's what people love.
You know?
They don't want you.
If you were only like a history guy and they were only talking about Chinese
history,
you know what I mean?
How many,
how many podcasts on history can you list for you?
Like,
do you guys talk about Stinky Posey and never?
Is there a stinky pussy conversations to be had?
Apparently Eddie Bravo,
last one I told you he went on that whole stinky pussy,
dirty feet,
stinky foot.
He has one of the greatest stinky pussy,
stinky feet stories ever.
But having sex with a stripper in a backseat of a car when she had a yeast
infection and her feet stunk.
Could you pin stripping all night?
What's funny about that?
It doesn't stop a man.
You know,
you're like,
fuck it.
Let me just hold my breath.
How many times you're bang grown,
you smell shit.
You smell her,
but it's like she didn't wipe it.
Well fuck down and you can see like a little bit of shit that's happened me,
it's happened to me.
And guess what?
Didn't,
didn't affect my heart on one one bit.
That can be pretty gross though.
I still have a vision of this like little Dab of Shit that I saw at my
girlfriend's ass when I was like 21 that's a huge,
because I remember it.
You know what happened to me?
I was in New York City and I remember like meeting this girl sexy and then we
were making out and then we've had sex and then I turned her over and she had a
hairy ass and I'm talking about thick black hair and I was like all over us.
It was all of her cheeks.
It was thin,
but you know it was,
it was there and then,
and then she had a real real hair and see the old cracker row and I was like,
this is like fucking a guy and I couldn't fucking do it.
I just was like my eye that just came to me.
How have you thought about that in a long time?
How was she on the one who knows a seven for the story?
Yeah,
until she turned over.
And then she was a guy and that made her,
you know,
not tend to track that made her 10.
Wow.
So what did she say when you,
I didn't say a goddamn thing.
No.
What did she say when you just sort of stopped?
I don't know.
I can't remember.
I just remembered this story.
So if I said I'd been making it up,
but I know me,
I know I probably did the old Ah,
my fucking storm or on this condoms burning my dick.
I'm bad with latex.
I had something like that.
This,
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta get her to think I'm gonna throw up,
I guess.
I think a poison.
I have somebody poisoned me.
Look,
there's been some people that have been thinking about poison,
hairy ass.
Hairy ass.
What in your fucking mind?
How about looking in the mirror?
Sometimes you've got to check the backside.
Well,
you are my,
so you remember back in the high school days where no one ever,
she took care of their pussy.
Nobody's,
no one shares.
Get these malls.
And by the way,
I didn't care.
Porn changed that,
right?
For all women because women didn't shave their pussies back then.
Every of women shave their pussy.
I mean,
I don't think it's all women.
I think some women are like feminist holdouts.
They like,
you know,
like,
I don't feel like I should,
you know,
any girls getting laid is,
is shaped one central.
There's a lot of girls out there with a hairy box.
Let's just say general things and dudes who just deal with it,
just take it.
If it's not too bad,
like what if she has naturally not that much hair,
not that bad,
like Norwegian or some shit.
It's fine from Iceland.
Tiny thin white hairs.
It's firely shit.
But if she's Greek,
she's a girl.
She's Italian Greek letter.
They're so beautiful.
You ever been to Greece?
I've lived there.
Lived there for three years.
Did you really?
Yeah,
in Athens.
And then I went to the islands.
I remember the Algebra one taste.
My Dad was working there.
But um,
when my,
uh,
well I went to,
I went,
I was in fourth,
fifth and sixth grade.
And in Greece you can live then all the time.
Not really,
but I went back to the islands and I went to Mykonos
I remember and I was 21 or 2120 and it was the one of the greatest trips of my
life and I've never seen,
I've never seen more beautiful women in my life really in my life because they
were Italian,
French,
Vegas and I've been to Vegas.
Yes.
Wow.
What thing is by the way is underrated.
Vegas has some of the best looking woman you'll ever say.
Well they're not really,
they're coming from all over the world.
True as what it is like a center point for attention.
We're getting Ooh,
glitzy shit.
Yeah.
I went there.
When I go to Vegas I played pool like easily cause the one of the last places
where you can play pool 24 hours a day.
Wow.
Yeah.
Vegas has 24 hour pools.
Those don't really exist in most parts of the world.
Right.
They're done.
It's over.
New York used to have a gang of them.
La had one.
They the last time we had one in La was the La Earthquake.
Just for pleasure.
It's always more work.
Yeah.
Really?
I don't gamble,
you know.
So I've gone to Vegas for fights back in the day four.
I used to work for the UFC.
Yeah.
Well that's right.
Where did we go?
What do we go to see?
Those was before I was working for them.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
I remember you and I go into one.
We went to one in baton rouge,
Louisiana when a guy named Randy couture had had his first fight,
I think.
Yeah.
And uh,
and I remember we went,
I went,
well,
you and I were at the one where Randy couture beat Vito Belfort.
Remember that if you taught was like back then,
that was a few Toros,
240 pounds.
He was how he just putting some,
uh,
one of lucky charms in the cereal every morning.
Fucking,
I mean,
here's this guy who was size eight feet to 40.
They looked like a color of a plum.
Nick was like a lion.
He's,
yeah,
he's a stud.
But then his,
I guess his trainer,
uh,
who was 34 years old,
died of a heart attack.
I think,
okay,
well it was this big giant bodybuilding dude that he's to hang around with.
Yeah.
We used to call them garden hoses because you had these arms and with veins that
look like garden hoses.
Yeah.
It was unbelievable.
I look to them,
you're like,
how has that a human who's so
big crazy and he was probably helping get Victoria could be get bodybuilder big.
Well,
it's interesting,
um,
the,
uh,
the whole debate on a performance enhancing drugs and testosterone and stuff
like that.
What's really interesting about it is it's,
it's jumped the fence into the women's division now,
cause you know,
Ronda Rousey is the woman's champ.
They,
they opened up 135 pounds for women now.
So she's going to headline the first ever woman's like,
well first woman's fight is going to headline a UFC and a,
it's going to be an Anaheim.
And at one 35 is where she's the champ.
But at one 45 was that cyborg chick,
the one who's built like a dude,
but she got popped for steroids.
Yeah.
So now that trying to see if they can get Cyborg to drop to one 35 but she's
like,
I can make one 35
where is she from?
Brazil.
Yeah.
I don't like the,
I don't like that fight for Ronda Rousey first of all because I love Rousey
because I have
a huge crush on Ronda Rousey.
Jay Moore,
I did his podcast.
He's like,
well if you were dating her,
how would you date somebody you know,
could kick your ass.
Like,
oh,
I would train every single day and in a year or two years I'd figure her out and
I'm still 170 pound man and we'd have our,
we'd have,
I would be just fine on the mat as far even as great as she is.
As a guy.
I'll take the beating because I love her.
She could tap you right now.
Yes.
I don't train.
I haven't enrolled,
but Ronda Rousey as we walk out there living with that.
That's why I'm training.
That's why I just bought a bunch of mats.
You joking me.
Of course.
But,
but,
uh,
I gave that ghost up a long time ago.
I mean,
I just knew I was never going to be,
you know,
but,
but a female,
I just got too many friends who were fighting to see what they can do to me and
yeah.
And I'm not going to be,
I'm not going to be in the,
I,
I could never even,
even Rhonda to me is so pretty.
I wouldn't ever want to punch her in the face.
She's just too hot to me.
Yeah.
And I love her.
She pay you back while you're sleeping?
She'd kicked my foot.
Yeah,
that's right.
You couldn't,
if you cheated on her or something,
I'd be so fucking high.
He did.
You'd have to be really worried about it.
Should break your arm.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
she's,
she had like three different chicks.
Are She dating anybody?
Me.
She takes another one,
I think is adorable.
She's to me,
she's got a boyfriend who's an MMA fight.
I am Bryan Caraway.
Really cool guy.
Yeah.
He was on the ultimate,
how's she doing?
How's her arm?
It was fun.
Yeah.
She's back.
I don't like seeing girls hurt each other.
I hate that shit.
Well,
you know where is going to do it too?
She's the armbar assassin.
She just goes for armbars.
It's hard to protect the guy.
It's hard to get an arm bar against the high level black belts to,
well,
when she was a little girl,
you know her mother raised her and her mother raised her to be a judo champion.
Her mother was a judo champion,
which she was a little girl.
She would wake her up and make her do armbars.
Wow.
Wake her up like casual Arbella here,
go get it.
And she would like throw her hips up and throw it like,
wow.
She's been doing it since she was a baby.
She's a baby.
There's like a fluidity in efficiency when someone is really fucking good at
some point that that she has like when she swings her legs over for that Shit,
she's done that 100 million times.
She just whipped 10,000 hours.
10,000 hours.
Yeah.
There's certain moves,
man.
It's really funny,
but the way you can relate it is tying your shoes.
You know how you tie your shoes,
you don't think about tying your shoes,
you don't think,
well,
I going to have been this.
I'm going over,
loop it with that and then I'm going to go through that.
You don't think about it.
You just go like that and your shoes are tie.
Yeah.
Well that's what happens with fighting to that same thing.
When you find,
even if you've been wrestling and somebody grabs you,
I moved to the side,
I'll,
I'll be working your arm.
You know,
you just kind of have a reaction to and with especially a lot of people have
like pet moves,
you know,
they have this one move.
They could just hit it like Joe Lowe's on,
just see the last Jolo was on flight.
He's got that crazy,
he'll hook,
had kid's a stud.
He's a tough kid,
man.
It's very tough.
But,
but uh,
um,
so it was Miller.
Miller is a fucking savage.
That was tough.
That was his best fight to date.
I mean,
unbelievable.
Unbelievable fight.
He is as tough as it gets.
It's below sack and forth.
It was crazy.
It was a complete insanity.
What a fight.
There's so many killers in these divisions that being a fighter is so fucking
difficult.
But one of the GSP does is I think that makes him so good is he'll find out
where your strength isn't just w and just not,
not engaged.
That strength,
you know?
Yeah.
And do things that you don't expect.
He'll,
he'll,
well he's so good at mixing up the takedowns and the,
he's gonna fight next to as,
and that's going to be a tough one for him.
It's going to be exciting.
You should come.
I will.
Cause I had Nick Diaz,
I love water comes in Montreal.
I would,
when is it?
I yes,
I'm march.
I'll tell you right now.
I've got to make sure I'm not doing a Gig.
It's a,
I think it's like March 15th or some shit.
March 16th March 16th in Montreal.
If you want it,
you could do a Gig with me the night before.
You know what?
Yeah,
because I,
and then I have to be a wait March 16th hold Eddie.
If by March,
March,
what,
what is it?
March 16th and we could do a theater together on the 15th dude,
that's great.
Okay.
I'm quite sure I'm free.
Yeah.
All right.
You and me,
there'll be fun.
I love it.
Okay,
look,
we're going to book something cause I was just going to book a comedy club
because I have a,
I have to give these people a whole lot of new material cause I was just in
Montreal recently but he'll just forced me to write.
We'll have some fun.
Montreal is great.
Just say Eddie F's on the show tonight.
Also Eddie's on the ice house shot.
Beautiful tickets at ice house.
One interrupt us and talking about something about yourself in the middle of us.
Tone.
Yes.
The 10 minute podcast.
Oh three we're in top three comedies of 2012 so listen you in top three new
comedies to have three new comedies in 2012 which was really cool.
I was awesome man.
Was it good?
And I'm,
I'm coming up on our hundredth episode.
How often you guys do it,
do you know?
We meet every two weeks and a whole bunch of them.
And then who puts them out?
Oh,
well Sasa.
So he added some and everything.
Yeah,
edits.
He does it all.
He's a nut really.
And he's,
he's just fucking hilarious.
And all of them are 10 minutes long.
Yeah.
I think will Sasso to me,
and I'm not bullshitting.
I think he's truly the most,
he's the,
the,
the most talented actor,
comedian and all around talent I've ever,
I've ever been around.
I've never seen anybody sing.
He can dance.
He can fucking depression there.
I don't need to see you saying.
Right.
Well that's what I mean.
But nobody,
she can do basically everything and nobody knows it.
Like if the world,
it's just this business,
but he's as good.
He could do anything.
Anybody out there can do and as well or better in building.
Damn,
dude,
he's,
he's sick.
Daniel Day Lewis.
You think he can,
he can do it.
I think if you gave will and you gave will a role,
he had to be grading.
I think he would win an Oscar.
I think he's,
I think he is giving love.
I think he's Oscar caliber.
I've actually honestly never seen anybody that talented I and he does shit.
He does shit out of nowhere on the podcast.
It's a fucking way better than me.
You're having a lot of man thoughts.
So he'll do shit like out of the blue on the podcast where I go,
how the fuck is he doing this?
How was he coming up with this?
It kills me.
He's amazing.
Do you guys know about this whole Al Jazeera current TV thing?
No,
it's really fascinating.
Uh,
current TV,
which is Al Gore's network.
He just sold that to Al Jazeera.
No.
So now al Jazeera has access to millions of US viewers.
It's really kind of fascinating.
And I think time Warner drop them or Cox cable dropped them.
I shouldn't speak out of school.
So let me Google language in media wars.
Yeah.
Cox Drops Al Zero drops.
What's his name is Morgan Stanley by The Washington Post recently.
Jamie diamond who did Jamie diamond of Morgan Stanley and Morgan Stanley bought.
Really?
Yeah.
Can you look that up?
Time Warner dropped current TV.
So Time Warner cable drop them because Al Jazeera bought them.
That's fascinating.
Meanwhile,
I'll just,
zero has good fucking news.
I listen to Al Jazeera there.
They seem to have pretty unbiased news,
which is something that American we can fucking use.
Yes,
we could.
Well the problem is that it,
like we always talk about it really does seem like not only a corporations at
corporate interests had never been a corporate corporate powers,
never been so concentrated.
Campbell soup controls 70% of all the shelf space for a soup,
a Colgate,
Palmolive,
I believe control 83% of all the soap and toothpaste you buy a corps.
Uh,
and then Heizer Bush are the distributors of all beer.
And so they,
they have such power and concentrations of,
of money and power that it,
it's very easy to manipulate government to give yourself an advantage in the
market.
And that goes along with news as well.
Yeah.
And that's a whole,
I hope that's not happening with news,
but it seems it is.
Oh well it's been for awhile line with Fox News being complete.
That's leaning.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's a threat to our democracy.
I was watching Fox News when they were joking around about like,
can we get rid of the president?
You like say this was right after the election and they will like,
someone said something and someone said,
well,
can we send the president over there too?
Oh,
like God,
I don't think we can.
But it was like,
it's supposed to be news.
It's supposed to be unbiased.
Exactly.
It's not just supposed to be news,
but the w what they're joking around about is not really even funny or a joke.
And what they're doing is just letting everyone know that much like you,
we are upset with this,
win this victory.
Right?
Because the victory of Obama does not go along with the programming of this
network.
Well,
by the,
by the way,
networks now news program networks,
that famous story was in the 70s when the good news that came in and said 60
minutes for the first time got really high ratings,
bad news for the first time.
I got high ratings.
In other words,
news has now become something you can tell advertising on.
Never shouldn't be the case.
And in fact,
uh,
news has now become entertainment.
You also have a channel called CNN or Fox that has to fill content with a lot of
stuff over,
you know,
24 hours.
Then again,
what's the,
what's the option?
The option is like PBS,
which sucks a fat Dick.
The option,
I don't know the honest I do.
I do think it's up to consumers and I think it's up.
I think it's up to just educating yourself.
I love it here,
but it's up to educators.
Stop it.
You don't love NPR.
There's a lot of NPR that is filled with people who talk like this.
This is NPR.
We don't have emotions.
We don't have feelings.
We're just giving you the facts.
We are live from Afghanistan where his so what?
Right now it's not,
there's nothing about NPR that's exciting cause they don't have to compete.
So they're not interesting.
They're not entertainer.
I listened for as listen just because they got interesting perspectives.
Are Authors and stuff like that on?
Well,
they're allowed to do things because it's,
you know,
it's sort of public,
public funded.
They can get away with things that you can't get away with it.
You're competing in
public market.
Well they can get into segments like in depth and stuff.
A lot of times what you're,
what you,
you know,
these,
these news programs have to keep everything in a chunk because they have to cut
the advertising.
So you get bumper sticker,
you know,
very kind of periphery ideas of what's really going on on the ground.
Uh,
and,
and I don't think it's the best way to get your news.
Well it's also what national public radio does is so boring and they interject
all these ads,
these pledge drives and shit and that,
yeah,
that,
that's,
that's the only four times a year.
But it doesn't matter when it happens.
Like they need to go podcast style.
That's what they should've done a podcast of the answer to all that shit because
there's no way you can have a conversation with someone.
They're like,
we're doing in any other format.
Right.
It's no way you can have a three hour open ended conversation cause they don't
exist.
Right.
They fucked it up with this.
You okay over there?
Do you just try and make noise?
The um,
they,
they fucked it up with,
you know,
with being boring and they fucked it up with their,
their pledge drives that make your brain bleed.
There's a fucking Terence Mckenna interview and I swear to God,
this guy,
every five minutes interrupts transplant.
Kevin says,
and if you're enjoying this conversation with Terrence,
this is one of the things that we offer here.
And if you could just donate some of,
I mean we,
we this,
these,
we may not be,
that's better than having advertisement every time you have it.
No,
it's not.
it's not every five minutes.
This fucking Douche bag.
That's literally as a week out of every four months.
I mean,
I don't know if that's the case in this guy with this one.
Radio shows hold up members,
so I know Barf,
right?
Interviews.
Terry Gross always has something.
Somebody in [inaudible] of course you give them 50 bucks a month.
Do they do,
they should be able to delete those stupid pledge drives from you.
You should be able to press up.
Well,
they,
I have a lot of power.
And recently my,
my new decision is not a,
now I don't have,
I try not to have an opinion unless I've read at least two books on something
like now.
Um,
and even when you read a book,
it's so funny.
Everything I mentioned to you,
Republic loss,
Lawrence less book,
I'm trying to get him my fucking podcast.
He's so fucking smart,
but he just talks about the only issue,
the only issue we should be talking about is money in politics.
Right?
And all donations should be anonymous.
Entity has got different ideas about it,
but,
but he just makes a really good case of all the stuff that we talk about,
about of corporate power,
about what money does when you're a congressman,
it's not about being a Democrat or Republican,
you spend all your time basically raising money to get elected again and just
kind of what it does and stuff.
But I just find that so many issues that you try to get into like this gun issue
and stuff like that,
they're fucking complicated and,
and trying to really earn an opinion takes a lot of investigation.
A lot of times I don't have time to do it.
And there's so many ways.
There's so many different perspectives,
perspectives to look.
I,
you know,
alarms.
Sam Harris wrote a very,
uh,
interesting and really well thought out piece about it.
If you go to Sam's webpage,
I think it's Sam Harris.
Dot Org.
Uh,
you can,
uh,
you can download it and read it,
but it made some really good points about guns.
Yeah.
Well about the whole issue.
You know,
what we're dealing with.
Well,
Nicholas Christoff had a really interesting article that I kind of got,
got my attention where in Australia in 1982,
forgive me if I'm getting the dates wrong.
1984 to 96 in 1,996 and 12 years,
they had,
um,
uh,
I think 16 or 19 mass shootings accommodating with 35 people being killed in one
time in [inaudible] 96.
It was a huge thing in Australia and they passed I believe,
three different measures.
One was a 28 day waiting period.
I think another was the type of weapon you can actually get.
And then they bought back 650,000 guns.
And by the way,
everybody,
I'm paraphrasing the article,
I don't know if that's exactly what it was.
Three of those majors since then,
they've had no,
no mass.
It had no mass shootings.
I'm just saying when I hear that,
I go,
the only thing as I say is I go,
I don't know if that's the answer.
I just say that I don't like when the NRA says,
well,
there's nothing we can do about crazies.
Yeah,
there is that.
There's gotta be a way to solve this problem.
I don't feel like having my kid not be safe at school.
I,
there's gotta be something.
There's a discussion to be had about,
we already have caps on lethality.
You can't buy a fully automatic machine gun unless you have a really intricate
license and go to a lot of the stuff.
You can't actually carry a gun out in the open unless you're in Arizona.
And even that's difficult,
right?
We do have laws on the books.
Is,
is there,
is there a discussion to be had about,
you know,
I dunno,
I find I'm very careful with this cause I just don't fucking know
God,
there's a real issue though.
I mean what's what we were talking about earlier,
there's a real issue that people have one side or the other.
You know,
I've seen so many tweets that were like,
well,
too bad if you,
if you,
uh,
if you like hunting,
get a new hobby.
Like I actually saw that somebody wrote that.
Fuck,
people having guns.
If you like hunting,
get a new hobby.
Like that's,
that kind of stupidity exists too.
There's,
there's,
there's one side that doesn't want to give at all and the sales side,
it doesn't want to give.
Right.
All.
And somewhere along the line,
again,
like I said,
the real issue is mistaken and overlooked.
And that issue is what the fuck is happening to people.
That it's allowing them to do that.
Right?
What is,
what is allowing someone to completely lose their humanity because it doesn't
just have to be a gun.
You know,
Timothy Mcveigh did it with fertilizer guy did it in China.
22 kids with,
with a knife.
Yeah.
You could,
you,
there's a lot of ways you could kill people.
Yeah.
Did you hear about these assholes in Indiana that a blue their house up and
killed their neighbors?
No.
Yeah,
it's fascinating cooking math.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the,
an insurance scam.
They,
um,
they took out all their important paperwork and uh,
some,
some valuables and then they opened up the valves of the gas that goes to the
stove and the gas that goes to the fireplace.
And then they set the timer on the microwave.
So that timer on the microwave went off at a very specific time.
And when it sparks,
I don't know if they put like metal in it or something.
I guess that's what you do.
Um,
it just blew the house to Smithereens and blew the neighbor's house to
smithereens to kill the neighbors.
Crazy fucking assholes.
And by the way,
they didn't think they could figure this stuff out.
Well,
these dump fucks left the gas on for hours before the microwave went off.
So you're talking about a giant cloud of,
oh,
we'll just wide open gas being pumped into this spot.
All the doors shut,
all the windows sealed.
It was like a gas balloon in there.
And so when that bomb went off,
I mean,
you're talking about it obliterated the house.
It's unbelievable.
So I talked about it yesterday and the podcast and somebody put a link up to the
actual story that they,
actual stories,
mindblowing,
killed names to fuck heads.
Yeah.
So they're in jail now for murder.
And that workout,
that insurance scam,
some people really fuck up.
It must be such a surreal thing to be like,
I wanted to make some money and now I'm going to be in jail for the rest of my
life.
You know what?
They were doing a lot in California.
They were getting uh,
people and they would slam the brakes on in front of them.
People would slam in them and they said,
oh my neck.
And they were suing insurance companies.
There was like super common.
The other thing they were doing is they'd come in and get some obscure,
you'd have a business mom and pop shop and they would sue you based on some
weird obscure law and then get you to settle out of court.
Have you ever seen a video of people faking falls?
Yes.
That's beautiful.
I've seen some of those markets.
You're on fucking video dumped down.
It's hilarious.
They didn't know.
You know,
people didn't know how much shit was videotaped until they tried a few of those.
Last thing that I noticed now in my life in 2013 everywhere you go,
they're watching you.
Everywhere you go,
hotels,
anywhere you go,
you're being watched.
Yeah.
Traffic.
It's just interesting in some ways makes you safer in another way.
It's like,
you know,
as long as it's not one central hub and one group of people watching,
it's a lot of different people watching af fuck it.
It's a lot of different people watching,
but who gets to,
who gets to decide what gets watched?
Cops get this list.
Cops.
Yeah,
the cops will.
Obama just signed a very controversial bill that was five more years of
warrantless wiretapping so that the feds are allowed to just beside it,
listen to it on your phone calls anytime they want.
Like how did that happen?
No warrants like are the judges of that fucking visit idea?
Is that yeah,
that that takes a long time.
You've got to go through all these channels.
Sometimes they need access immediately.
Cops have been proven over and over again to have issues and be corrupt.
Especially costings.
What if a cop like,
like the girl,
if you're trying to solve a problem,
shit,
trying to solve a problem,
you're going to fucking do.
You get like,
it's like the deer.
I was supposed to shoot a buck.
Then we were on the other side where you could show a dope.
I was like I'm not gonna shoot a doe.
Not on camera.
That is fucking,
I had three hours the guy,
cause you want to shoot a dog,
I'll fucking shoot anything.
I asked you to human in a deer suit.
Just let me,
let me open fire on this pocket thing.
You know,
you,
you get an objective and you're going to bend the rules.
You know,
that's super common with cops.
I mean the planting evidence,
planting,
God's got to this.
There's gotta be a way that you could figure out how,
you know,
if someone's telling the truth.
And right now there's not,
and since there isn't there,
you know,
people can fuck with things and Ben things and how things are going to take
their,
they're going to,
I can lie detector test or are inadmissible.
Yeah,
it does.
You don't have to take them.
And if you do take them,
they don't count in court.
So it's not even,
it doesn't matter.
You can't even bring it up.
Right?
Like you don't even think you're allowed to bring up polygraphs.
Well,
because they don't work on sociopathy stay really calm.
They had done lying to them.
Is that because lying is about,
about,
you know,
basically not looking good in front of somebody.
You're trying to hide something and you're,
their approval means something to you.
So she'll pass.
Don't have that.
That's why they can stay so calm under pressure.
That's creepy.
And it just so fucking calm with Bernie Madoff.
There were saying that after it was over,
like he didn't give a fuck.
He was always like,
I want to,
I need orange juice,
orange juice.
Like little like you do realize what the fuck just happened.
You just rob people of billions of dollars.
You crushed people's dreams.
People committing suicide,
including your son.
Yeah.
I need owner there.
Our shoes here.
Like it was just what he had in his mind,
what he wanted to such a back.
Apparently his wife slipped away.
She's,
his wife apparently slipped away with some money to,
well she couldn't,
I don't think she could even get her nails done where she was living.
So not where she was living.
She had to go to another spot.
But that bit's moved to Beverly Hills.
No one's going to know who she is.
No,
change your last name.
Gives a fuck around.
There we go.
Fly early.
Hells in some ways it's the worst place in the planet I've ever been to.
In what way?
I've never seen creepier looking people in my life.
I've never seen.
Uh,
I just find it just,
I went to Barney's because there was a sale for it.
That's my first mistake because I'm going to buy clothes and her bike clothes.
I wear t shirts and jeans.
I'm like,
I'm going to go by when you worked fancy shoes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I try zippers on the side of them,
like my Nike phrase right now and I go,
yes I do.
By the way,
I was like,
I'm going to buy some boots with a zipper on the side and this is the year I
wear a leather shirt jacket and by the way,
I'm going to get some cashmere zipper hoodie sweater cashmere cause they are
soft and they're sexy,
blah blah,
blah.
Fucking didn't buy anything because I have no patients.
I get there,
I'm like,
I can't try the shit on.
I'm exhausted.
And meanwhile it's just that you just see these,
these fucking dudes who,
who've never done a pushup,
but they're spending a fortune $700 on shoes.
They don't have the scaffolding.
Their bodies are all soft and Shitty from chasing that dream and climbing that
wall that they don't even want to be on top of.
And now they've got money to buy awesome threads in there,
46 years old and they got that great convertible and they're going to pick up
chicks tonight but they got to where?
Bucking ostrich skin boots and,
and you know,
felt a felt hat with a fucking scarf by Air Mez.
And you just want to be like,
dude,
just end it.
Jump out that window right now cause he'd be presence is depressing.
Mish.
Oh yeah.
Oh fuck yeah.
Hey listen,
I walk around with $30,000 on my body peasant.
No,
not for me.
Yeah,
it's a weird thing,
isn't it?
The showing all the wardrobe,
like the,
the wealth showing the wealth of my buddy told me he spent $140 on a haircut.
I remember,
I never forgot this.
He got to spend 140 bucks on a haircut too.
But I feel it's worth it.
I was like,
I'm not friends with you anymore.
How's that sound?
I just on principle can't hang out with you.
He said he feels it's worth it.
Yeah,
they really,
they really layered it though.
They knew how to what?
What do you think of my hair?
He was like dead serious.
I was like,
how about I punch you in the face?
What do you think we're right hand you fucking idiot.
Well,
this is something that is very east coast,
especially where they just don't tolerate preening.
No,
you don't fucking,
that's that is correct,
sir.
I told you when I shut up with my,
my leather fucking awesome leather pants from France and you want the leather
belts.
I was in fucking France and as this,
this hot sales woman had me try on a leather jacket and she goes,
sits [inaudible].
And he said,
it's really good.
I go,
oh,
Mixi Buku and then she goes,
you know,
we have a really Newton news.
I've owned two,
but [inaudible] booked was that,
I was like,
okay,
so pants.
Should I put on chocolate suede leather pants dude and hold wait for it.
Bought a pair of boots that went with them.
Meanwhile,
I go boots that go with that.
That's,
that's exactly right.
I literally shut my buddy's like,
what the fuck?
I come out of the,
my friends are watching hockey.
They turn around and go,
fuck,
has he gotten his legs?
I go,
no,
I got these.
These are leather pants.
They jumped on me as a group without even a signal and pulled them off and throw
them out the window.
That was the last time I ever fucking saw my $300 pair of leather pants,
and that's one of the good things about being on the east coast,
you know?
Fuck.
Yet.
It's one of the good things about being on the east coast as you,
there's a lot of shit that they get away with an la that you just could do it.
I showed up the first time I saw Jimmy Burke when I got home after mad TV,
I decided to wear a fucking hat.
I'm a hat guy now,
apparently because I'm on TV in La.
It was a fucking Kangol hat.
No,
but I had it turned around backwards.
And you know,
it doesn't look bad.
It's just that it's not me.
I'm not that guy.
I never wear hats.
And Jimmy knew it was suddenly,
oh,
I'm going to wear fucking a hat.
And I had an awesome like awesome shirt that I bought with like cool design.
Jimmy could see right away.
I walk in,
he goes,
dude,
it's so fucking good to see you,
man.
I can't.
I'm so proud of you.
Take the fucking hat off for right now.
I'm gonna slap the Shit Outta here.
Like did he didn't miss a beat.
We missed up Jimmy Burke's introduction to the world.
We got them too high,
too high,
and he didn't
know what the fuck the deal.
Didn't know what dude,
he passed out in the car on the way back.
Yeah.
Why don't you guys try to go deep with us.
They don't know what the fuck they're getting into.
We've got to get back.
We'll get it back.
So if you're not a regular marijuana smoker or if you're smoking marijuana from
other parts of the country,
especially if you're smoking marijuana from a place that doesn't have a medical
marijuana program,
the odds of you getting like really good stuff,
they drop significantly.
He hadn't slept,
he hadn't eaten and he doesn't smoke a lot of weed.
I smoke your weed one time when I was a high for seven hours.
How about that?
That's,
that's a good,
that's a good batch.
That's how it's supposed to be.
Why would you want some fucking shit?
I'm still fucking high.
I've had two meals.
You're like,
that's how he rolls on.
That's not helpful.
It's got to go there and stop being such a control freak.
Right?
Hey,
thanks Linda Goldman.
So people were asking me when you guys went hunting,
did you guys smoke weed out there?
No,
you don't need,
we'd like,
you know,
people that think that you need,
we'd always to have a good time.
They're just a silly is that people think you don't need weed to have a good
time.
Like you know,
you don't,
I want to go shoot hogs.
Anything.
I want to go shoot hogs and northern California.
Well Dude,
we could do that too.
All right.
We can,
you know,
we could definitely shoot pigs.
They're wild pigs are,
there's a season,
the,
it's 24 hours a day,
seven days a week,
all year round.
Especially in Texas.
In Texas.
You could shoot them at night.
You put flashlights on them and blast them can see.
You could trap them in Texas.
You could shoot them from helicopters.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
You can drive in your truck,
roll down the window and shoot them out the window.
Yeah.
They opened up a new highway in Texas and the first night for people ran into
pigs with their call and the first night for accidents.
That was a huge,
huge,
two 5,300 easy,
no problems and just slamming into them at 80 miles an hour.
1200 pounds or something.
Yeah,
the really well Hogzilla if you've seen Hogzilla.
I don't know how much that fucker.
I think that's probably more than what it was.
I think it was a feral pay.
A pig will go feral in the wild in like three weeks,
in three weeks,
three weeks.
I thought it was three generations knew.
Three weeks in three.
They're the one of the only animals that physically morphs when it's removed
from domestication,
something happens to them.
When we're feeding them and we're taking care of them and we keep them in a pen,
they stay like white and pink.
When they get out in the wild,
their hair changes within three weeks,
it starts to happen.
Their hair starts to change,
their tusks grow and their nose extends.
It's crazy.
Wow.
They'd completely become a different angle.
I think there also are,
aren't in northern California.
They have some,
they have,
what are we going to be hot and we're not going be,
we're gonna be having a Russian.
Well they,
there's that,
there's that as well.
Russian wild boars.
Um,
they,
they introduced those,
but they also started interbreeding with pigs and that's some of the larger
ones.
Some of the larger wild pigs that you find are hybrids.
And they said that was about,
um,
Hogzilla was one of those,
how do we find them in northern California?
Did you have to,
Ella was telling us that,
um,
there was a place that he has a friend that has a ranch and they show up every
morning at the,
at the river,
you know that there's a river that runs through the ranch and all you do is you
get there in the morning and you go by the river or your weight or creek,
whatever the fuck it is.
The pig show up and you blast one.
That'd be a short hunting trip though.
So what,
it's not an entity like doing it all day.
How about fun?
But we were fine.
We were so fucking called the first night,
second night,
and we were sleeping in tents.
Take,
you're taking dumps outside and he's thing sucks eating that shitty food.
And I,
we're both freezing.
I just here I can jump off camping alone.
Yeah.
We talked about this before.
The first night we did it,
the first night we got there,
it was pouring rain and was like,
wow,
what did we get into five days of this,
five days of being just freezing your ass off,
getting rained on.
He'll fucking fun.
Yeah.
Well that's why people do it.
You know?
I always wondered like,
why aren't we allowed that?
That seems like fucking gross.
There's no,
I have such a respect now for not only hunting but also the animals that was
haunting and and for the land.
You cannot be a good hunter the way those guys hunt and not actually have a deep
love.
I would argue that guys like Ryan,
our guide and Rinella have a much deeper love and certainly I've way deeper
understanding of animals,
animal behavior than anybody who doesn't hunt any Vegan.
Well you have,
I dunno,
I'd say more.
You know,
I'd say they definitely have a big love of it and a great appreciation for it.
I don't know what other people have what appreciation of Vegan house or,
I mean everybody's individual.
I don't think you can really generalize.
It requires a great deal of respect and,
and doesn't necessarily,
there's,
that's why Yahoo is go hunting too.
There's a lot of crazy fucks and go out there and they get hammered and shoot
that.
We did what we did.
I was impressed with how much we knew.
What we did is called a fair chase hunt,
you know,
but there's people in Texas that has high rate,
high fence,
high fence set up.
Like you can have a high five.
I saw one that was for sale that was 200 acres.
That's not that much.
And at 200 acres there's a gang of deer in there and you wonder around through
the woods,
you set up a fucking stand and you have feeders and there's a big thing is the
feeders.
Six o'clock in the morning you say it's boring.
I'd eat it,
I'll do it if I want to eat it.
I'd like harvesting.
That's called harvesting meet.
It's sort of,
it's,
it's not the same kind of hunting cause you know there's animals there,
but it's also those animals at least are living a natural life as opposed to the
animals.
That's what I mean.
It's harvesting your natural meat.
I'd call it target practice and the harvesting,
natural meat hunting to me is kind of what we did,
which was the idea of having to not only know where the animals were,
how they were going to behave,
where they were going to be getting up early because that's when they forward
all that stuff.
Glass in the field be gone three days without getting a deer.
You know that stuff.
Yeah.
Well that's,
I mean we did.
We're still super lucky.
You know,
we,
we both got a deer the first time we went hunting.
I had a friend when I was growing up,
David Abel and David's dad used to go out hunting every fucking year and this
guy never shot a deer.
He never shot a fucking deer.
He went every year.
The guy was a hunter and he's like,
you,
you know,
had my dad's a hunter,
but he's never shot a deer.
I go,
you dad's never shot a deer.
No,
I've never shot a deer.
How often does he hunted?
Every year.
He goes on every year.
I'm like,
dude,
you're doing something fucking Wayne Rod centers.
I don't know.
Well it's just people don't know what the fuck they're doing.
You know Rinella is like a legit hunter.
You know,
some people they just go wander through the woods.
Well hope a deer shows up soccer trued it.
Is this a good spot to stop mode?
We'll stop right here and wait for a deer and you might get lucky.
A deer might wander in front of you but most likely know,
especially when you're dealing with like heavily hunted woods,
you know,
like a big pressure.
Well they know the difference too,
dear know when they're being hunted,
you know it's,
it's Mike is smelling you like you gotta be real careful about the smell.
There was a couple times like when dear saw you,
they would let go.
What the fuck is that?
They would,
they would sort of stand around a little bit and look at you,
but if they smelled you they would fucking bolt.
Because we smell like killers.
Yeah.
We eat meat when it's not like mediators dear can really smell that.
And it's a trip to see.
We were up this on this Ridge and the wind was blowing behind us and straight
towards this deer and this deer looked at us and started fucking running just
full clip through the woods.
And I was like,
cause that,
cause he,
we saw him going,
no,
that wouldn't,
they wouldn't do it if they just saw us.
They smelled us.
They can see that's like elk.
Like you could smell it bad pussy.
But you know what?
Similar skunks,
you know,
like people say that our sense of smell is not that strong.
It's right.
But it is what skunks,
a skunk can have like one part per million.
You know,
like the amount of smell that a skunk releases from his ass is really not that
big.
But you could smell it in your car.
Oh yeah.
You can smell it in your car.
Air Conditioning.
When you're driving a half a mile away,
a skunk blasts a dog and you're half a mile away.
That's how that must have to be.
How dogs like pickup scent.
It is.
Supposedly that's the best.
And we can't normally,
we can't really wrap our heads around that until you bring up skunk and then
you'd go,
oh,
okay,
yeah,
why can I smell that?
I can smell the fuck on it.
Some skunk,
like bloodhounds.
Yeah,
but you could do that.
I mean,
imagine if you could do that with like fear,
you know,
we know where the fear is coming from,
or you smell a murderer.
You know,
that's what a deer is essentially saying that you can smell things and you don't
even realize,
but they register with you.
Like based on your child and this stuff.
Human beings pickup and minuscule,
they still,
we still pick from artists and,
and there's a great deal of information in that.
Well,
the idea of,
um,
one of the ideas there was bandied about about schizophrenia was that it was a
pheromonal disease and that people smelled you and you smelled wrong.
And so they acted weird to you.
And so you started thinking,
Oh wow,
I'm weird because people respond to me.
Weird.
Yeah.
And there's also,
um,
I think it's called Aloe phrenia.
And the idea is that if you are around a schizophrenia person,
like say if your schizophrenia and I go to visit you in the hospital,
it's possible that through me interacting with you,
I can exhibit schizophrenia behavior like the unknown,
unknown unheard of schizophrenia behavior before
you know,
um,
I remember there was a girl that was that I could never figure out why I wasn't
attracted to her and she always liked me.
I could never pull the trigger.
And I realized one day she didn't smell like anything cause a friend of mine
goes,
you know why I don't like her.
And I said,
why?
I said she doesn't smell like anything dude.
She doesn't have any scent and that,
and I was like,
and I would hug her and I go and there was nothing,
literally she had no scent is,
I don't even know how to describe it.
It was like this,
It was like,
um,
obviously there's a scent,
but it was scentless.
It was like a,
I dunno man,
it was,
oh wow.
A thing that people give off and I don't know if I'd call it a smell,
but I do call.
I always say it's a smell.
Like I could smell the crazy on this bitch.
I always say that
snow,
but it's not really a smell.
It's like a thing that people give off.
Well,
it's a rhythm.
You know,
pheromones or whatever that is.
Brian Keeley,
she's like,
if a guy doesn't smell right,
I'll just be like,
fuck it.
I don't care how awesome you are if you don't have the right sense.
She's well,
our friend Patty,
one time he or she ever tell you the story she was on.
She was,
I met this guy.
I actually knew the guy a little bit.
She went on a date with this guy like three times and he just didn't smell
right.
He didn't smell right.
She just didn't like the way he smelled and he ended up dying of AIDS.
He had aids.
Whoa.
She smelled him dancing.
She was like,
I just don't like the way he smells and I,
I just can't pull the trigger.
I don't want to kiss the guy.
I don't want it.
And then he ended up,
he turned out he was,
and I'm not saying all people that have aids snow,
but I'm just this guy,
no drug use or drug user.
He used to hit,
it used to be any,
got it that way,
but he was a,
he fucking ended up dying of it.
Wow.
You know,
that's fucked rank,
dark,
dark.
You know,
I still can't get anybody to fucking debate.
Peter Duesberg.
Matt stacks has tried time and time again.
He has reached out to all these,
searched out all these researchers,
all these,
um,
doctors that I've gotten,
people that's like,
or apparently researchers that have heard slurs at me and fucking,
you know,
said that,
uh,
um,
almost guilty of murder by having him on.
And I was like,
look,
I don't,
I don't have an opinion.
I'm not,
I've said it,
and I'll say it again with the aids thing or with HIV or any,
anything where I'm an educated in,
it's absolutely terrifying to be too stupid to know who's retarded because I
don't know.
I don't know if he's right.
I don't know if they're right.
I don't know what's going on the guy.
But I know the guy's brilliant and apparently has cancer research is top notch.
She's like made some leaps and bounds in cancer research.
He's got some really interesting work that he's done that's a very respected and
some of the most like is the first peer reviewed stuff in a long time.
But there's a lot of people that don't buy anything that he's saying it comes to
HIV
and AIDS and be tough.
There are a lot of people that have worked very closely with that virus and,
and so,
you know,
it seems that and,
and had been very,
very,
uh,
tireless in raising money for things in that,
you know,
things like keeping people on retro virals and things like that.
So I think that they,
there are a lot of people that seem to,
are in the trenches and do know a lot about it.
And maybe when someone like just very comes along and says something like that,
they're not even interested,
whatever his name is,
denied,
they're not even interested in debating it.
There are a lot of people would be like,
well,
it's too crazy to debate so well,
I think that any light that you could shed on and even if you're debating with
the idea,
is that if you,
you would give him power by addressing him as a,
you somehow give them legitimacy.
Yes,
I read his,
I read what he gave me and you know,
and,
and um,
what was the problem with it?
Was that,
not that he,
he had his point he had made,
but I didn't see enough.
It was just a paper.
There wasn't enough,
there wasn't enough pure reviewed,
uh,
cohabitation with the paper.
There wasn't enough sort of enough people saying,
yes,
we've done the same research,
we've looked at the same data and we concur that that was the only issue.
Um,
uh,
even though he was citing mainstream statistics,
like the World Health Organization and the United Nations and stuff like that,
those same organizations he's also arguing with yet he's using them as his,
you know,
points of reference.
So you know,
I read it and,
and and well that's because he was trying to make a point about the deaths in
Africa and like what everybody talks about like what aids was going to do to
Africa when in fact there's the same amount of people who have aids has had aids
back then.
But yet the population has tripled and it didn't have the same effect in the
population that everybody said it was and now he's got an absolute point.
Sure.
It's rock solid.
See,
it's not,
I don't think it's an either or.
I think what he's saying,
he has some very good points.
I wish someone would explain what's wrong with what he's saying.
Must be some,
well,
what he's saying I think is that he said that the h what's controversial,
it says HIV.
He,
he knows that there's HIV and he,
and he agrees there's age,
right?
They says HIV doesn't cause aids.
What causes AIDS?
You can have the HIV virus in your body.
If you live a healthy lifestyle and you're not doing poppers and drugs,
you know you,
you can survive with that and it will not manifest itself as aids.
Those that had HIV in there,
I think that is actually saying no.
What he's saying is that the evidence of HIV in your system is not evidence that
you have caught a aids and it's diminishing your immune system.
The evidence of age in your system is evidence of a diminished immune system
because that's the only way HIV exists in your system.
He's saying HIV is a weak virus and that the only way your body can't fight it
off is if your immune system is already compromised.
That's,
that's essentially saying and he believes that that compromising it's from drugs
and you know,
having a mom was a weird thing because,
you know,
look,
the guy says he wants to come on and tell a story.
I,
again,
I don't understand
enough of molecular biology to know if he's right or wrong,
but I do know that he's a fucking professor at Stanford,
Berkeley,
Berkeley Rather.
Yeah.
I mean he's a,
he's a Oh recognized guy.
I mean he's,
he apparently at one point in time before all this HIV aids thing was very well
respected,
but now he's a pariah.
I don't,
he may be crazy.
Oh yeah.
You know,
he may just be a complete Kook.
Uh,
we had a lot of weird shit.
They called black people's spots as,
and you know,
my vivid thing is the Nazi,
the gaze.
You can say,
it's funny,
you can say the gays,
but you can't say the blacks.
You can say the gays love disco,
but he can't see the blacks loved chicken.
You can't say that.
It's like,
you know,
there's a certain
ks love disco.
I didn't know you could say that.
They loved to dance.
You could say the gays love to dance.
I love to dance.
What's that movie?
Allee fuck yes.
I want to be a Spanish dancer.
I want to be a professional fucking so to be everybody.
That's what I want.
I put you don't want to be yourself.
Be Nick Diaz.
You want to be everybody to sell 10 a Karalyn.
I'm bored with myself.
What the fuck?
I want to be a fighter.
You've been yourself for too long and that's all it is.
I want to be,
if I want to be Joe Rogan.
You don't want to be mean.
No,
no.
All right.
It's too difficult.
It's a lot of work.
A lot of work.
It's contradictory.
Lyer on fucking warm water in the middle of the night and trying to figure shit
out.
It's too much work.
I know.
Better off having less questions.
A lot.
It's fucking,
that's all I have is better off being like a bowler,
you know,
something real simple.
Just concentrate on knocking those pins.
What?
Think about it,
if you could be one person and you could be one fucking person in the world and
it can't be you,
who do you think?
What would you be?
Bano Richard Branson.
I have never thought about that for even a second.
I've never spent any time wanting to be anybody but me.
Right?
Yeah.
I think you got this life.
I'm fucking super lucky.
You know you're super lucky and you could,
you could sue.
Boom goes,
look.
You know it was lucky.
I actually never feel that one.
No,
you're not that type of guy.
A lot of weak bitches that do that.
You know there's a lot of you,
you,
you use your talents that you have figured what the,
out what they are and then use them to the best of your ability.
And that's where the answers like,
I mean fucking,
you know,
enjoy it.
And you know,
this guy said something to him on the message board that said that,
uh,
I give too much.
I,
I'm a too much attached to the idea that I'm responsible for my own success.
And he was saying that a lot of people that are very intelligent people can
barely,
a rise above subsistence and the barely barely get through and feed themselves
and all you,
that is
horse shit.
That's the,
it's also not even the conversation to have.
It's also what's the point?
The point then as you're making,
well the point is
sang that,
you know,
I shouldn't be taking credit for anything that I've done and that I just got
lucky.
But that's ridiculous because what I got lucky at everything,
everything from martial arts to comedy to commentary,
to running a podcast,
all that shit's luck.
All that shit's,
that's crazy talk.
I like to say that someone is lucky because they've achieved success that you
have been able to achieve is so self serving and so stupid.
Of course it is.
It's also giving him,
it's also letting himself off the hook that that that luck is all chance.
There is law,
there is locking in and success.
There's a degree of always but but at the same time you're not serving yourself
in any way.
By even having that conversation with yourself,
you're making an excuse for yourself and and,
and even if your excuse is valid,
even if you actually have a great that you get,
you know you,
I don't know your whole family,
God forbid,
dies in a fire.
Nobody really at the end of the day cares.
You got to suck it up and figure out a way to make whatever happens to you,
work for you.
You can't control the weather,
but you can control how you react to it.
You show me a successful or you show me an intelligent person rather who is
involved in any sort of endeavor but is unsuccessful,
and I'll show you someone who's doing it wrong.
That's right.
That's all it is.
And there's,
if there's people that are doing it right,
there's look baby,
they got more opportunities than you did or then he did.
But maybe they got less than that guy and they managed to succeed anyways.
No,
there's no,
there's no evenness to the world.
You just have what you're handed as like these,
these,
this style of thinking that,
you know,
somehow or another we'll,
you know what man,
you just got real look and you should be really happy.
But all things should happen to,
you know,
barring health issues,
which many people will occur,
which can fucking completely blow up any plans that you have.
And you have to deal with cancer.
You have to deal with anything.
Barring that and barring psychological issues or mental deficiencies or anything
physical.
If you're a normal person and you have an interest in something,
the only thing that's stopping you from being successful if other people are
successful is you haven't figured it out.
Your methodology doesn't necessarily mean that you're a loser.
It could means you haven't figured out how to win yet or you're going to
eventually just haven't applied those to you.
Or You could even die as an old man who is still trying.
You're still not a loser.
You're just a guy who hasn't figured out how to be a winner.
By the way,
there there are.
There are ways to look.
Look for the people that are successful.
There are people that can show you how to manage yourself in image,
manage managing.
You know how you think about the world,
managing,
how you choose to react to things that happened to you in the world.
That's fucking very important.
Learning how to talk to yourself.
Here's the most important thing,
the most important thing,
so round yourself on other people who are doing the same.
That's right.
I will inspire you and who are,
who holds you to,
to uh,
to the same standard they hold themselves and are honest with you.
Yes,
very important.
When I grew up,
one of the big things about,
um,
growing up and being ambitious is I had two friends.
Both of them were named Jimmy,
Jimmy Smith or Jimmy did Teleo and Jimmy lawless.
There's two friends who both had businesses while I was in high school and these
motherfuckers would get up early.
And lawless was a contractor,
there was a carpenter and a to,
he was an electrician and he had employees.
What time?
We were 18.
This motherfucker had a truck,
he had employees,
he was getting up in the morning,
they were ambitious,
they got shit done.
And if you are a lazy fuckhead sitting around on your couch watching television
not doing anything,
they look that you look you were a loser.
And that work ethic,
that like sort of east coast work ethic,
having those guys around me when I was young,
when I,
even though I had this completely alternative way of living,
you know with the martial arts competitions and stuff like that,
I still,
I,
I knew dudes that worked hard and I,
I felt these,
my friends worked hard.
I have to keep myself up to that same sort of standard.
If I had a bunch of losers who are just smoking weed all day and sleeping,
who knows?
Who knows where.
I would be surrounding yourself with like ambitious,
positive people who are happy,
so fucking important and get and get clear on what you fucking want to.
That I always was kind of clear on I,
even when I didn't know what I want,
I knew I wanted something.
I always had an image in my head of,
I think that's really important.
I think that dude,
what are you doing?
Like I talked to a comic the other day and he's a really talented guy who
doesn't,
right?
And it isn't.
I don't end.
He's like pushing fucking 35 and I looked into Michael,
you're really talented guy and I saw you eight years ago and you had something
to say,
what are you doing?
What do you,
what's the point of what you're doing on stage?
There's no direction whatsoever.
He's like,
ah,
I dunno.
I go,
that's your problem.
You've got,
you've just stopped thinking about who you are,
what you're trying to do with this opportunity,
with this expression.
Is it just for the public embrace?
Is that all it is?
Some people definitely get stuck in a Rut.
That certainly has start asking yourself questions that help you out of that
Rut.
Then inspiration,
you know,
and that's one of the most beautiful things about podcasts is I think there's
more podcasts in more inspiration available in podcast form.
Then maybe in any other medium.
So it's just the conversations that we've had on this podcast and the 300 plus
episodes we have,
what are we up to?
Like three,
three plus 306 episodes.
We'd so many of them filled with inspirational people and it just conversations
like this when,
when I get emails from people telling me that,
you know,
I'd lost 90 pounds.
I got on Kale shakes ever since I started listening to your podcasts changed my
life is great.
I know,
but I then I know that I was,
I was on to something that it's not,
but there's a bunch of losers out there.
It's,
there's a bunch of people that are in bad patterns and they could be winners.
They just need to be around people that inspire them and get them on good
patterns and much like people getting fucking nutty about masturbation and
jerking off to their Dick Bleeds or getting nutty about washing their hands like
people can get on shit patterns.
They can get on these weird patterns.
There's a great article that I just interviewed her on my podcast,
Kristy [inaudible].
She is a professor at Princeton.
Sounds like a great porn star.
She's beautiful.
Beautiful.
She's new.
She's beautiful.
She's 35 years old and she wrote,
she wrote this incredible article called live without irony.
A Wampold is Christie got to be the seat and she's a professor at Princeton and
she's,
she speaks.
That's how strong that is.
That that's not,
that's me leading my button.
Well that's,
it took that picture.
I put it on a 10 minute podcast page.
Why would he be there while you're cleaning your butt?
Cause I was going look at my bud and cleaning it and he took that picture.
I mean that seems like changing.
Look at that back on me though.
I'll muscular shit.
I don't think you need to have that.
That's a dense,
that's I'm looking at how am I ask kind of,
are you happy with that?
Where that looks.
I like my body.
Um,
but she,
she,
in the article,
I read it four times,
the article she said,
she said,
and we,
but not to plug the fucking Brian Callen charge.
She's beautiful.
She's gorgeous.
And she had her on your [inaudible].
Brilliant.
I don't run the podcast.
Did you fall in love?
Yeah.
She's so smart.
And she's so,
she's,
she's so articulate.
And she,
and we,
she was talking about how hipster lifestyle is a product of,
it's,
it's a very good article,
but it hips walks style is basically a product of a generation of people who
feel like they have nothing to offer as far as new ideas or new thoughts or
anything like that attached.
Yeah.
And so what happens is there's this preemptive,
this,
it's called preemptive Lynn living ironic living the idea of I've already failed
that it,
so I'm going to poo poo it and not really try hard and trying hard and being
direct it and with what you want is considered very gauche.
It's considered kind of like uncool.
We've,
we've,
and the way she does it,
it's called live without irony or just listen to the podcast.
It's,
it's,
she's so she kinda encapsulates what bothers me when I walk into a coffee shop
and a guy's dressed like a 1920s conductor with a mustache and a hat and he's
just too cool for school and not really trying.
And that I could never put my finger on why that sort of hipster behavior got to
me and she captures it perfectly.
It's nothing wrong with tattoos.
Nothing wrong with dressing cool.
It's,
it's the attitude around sort of a,
a culture that doesn't believe they have anything to offer.
People who are pretending that it's cool to not care.
And it's never cool to not care.
That's stupid.
It's,
it's a total cop out,
right?
It gives a fuck stop.
It doesn't matter.
It does matter.
Every moment matters.
It doesn't matter silly.
You're being silly and you're wasting your life because every single moment
matters.
And the matters.
They're the moments that you feel with passion or more exciting moments,
they're more thrilling,
fulfilling.
They're more satisfying moments.
And for you to sit there with your fucking Cardigan on and pretend it doesn't
matter,
and you know you're a silly bitch,
you're lying to yourself.
You're align yourself and you're not going to get anything band you're being and
you're walking around a critic and a cynic,
so you have nothing to offer.
But criticism of people who really do try and you have and all you do is you can
come and say you're really lucky that you should feel really lucky that you're
doing well.
That has no relevance to anything.
Yes,
life has luck,
but I work really hard and I'm really direct and I go for what I want.
Yeah.
There was nothing wrong with that.
A bunch of people that don't want anyone to take any credit for anything that
they've done because somehow or other they feel that if you have succeeded in
any way,
shape or form on your own through without,
I mean without any approval like lottery style version of luck that been struck
you
how well it's,
could you be in a position that's ahead of me?
How else could you be in a position where you're making more money or you have
more success or you were by my age,
it has to be some lucky break.
Must've been bestowed upon.
What I say to people like that is stop looking at people that way.
Look at people in a different way.
Look at a guy like Joe Rogan.
Is it someone who's inspiring and going to fac I can do it.
That's an example of what I can do that can be empowering.
But if you sit back and decide in your head that,
well,
you know,
you have to realize that you got lucky.
Okay,
no,
I don't have to realize anything and you're being a silly fuck.
You're,
you're,
you're wasting thoughts.
You're not doing exactly.
You're not doing yourself any favor with that kind of thought.
I watched real housewives of Beverly Hills last night and talking about wasting
thoughts and uh,
fun.
And he just said that these wretched conch,
okay.
Which is what they are.
Some of them,
not all of them,
some of them.
I think that I feel bad for them that just women who need money and they're
stuck in these weird social situations,
but hanging out with these other clients and they're all vapid and they had a
like a 10 minute App,
part of an episode,
more than 10 minutes,
at least 15 minutes where they talked about whether or not a girl was rude for
telling another girl,
shut the fuck up.
And that's all they talked about.
Oh,
she was so rude,
you know?
Why didn't you say that?
She didn't have to say that.
Why did she say that?
I thought it was so rude.
Of course it's rude,
you know?
Well,
I think her point was,
well,
forget about where her point was.
That's human.
That's human beings who need conflict.
And if they don't have conflict,
I'm something to push against.
They'll,
they'll invent crazy social bullshit.
It was the whole episode and I was like,
this is so fascinating.
I watched a whole episode of Jersey shore and in the whole episode was the
situation wanting to leave the club,
but he wanted everybody else to leave too,
but they didn't want to leave.
So that was the whole episode was the situation.
Go,
come on,
let's get out of here.
Forget reading.
I'm going to watch Jersey shore.
They would pull the individuals aside,
you know,
in the style of the show.
Like there'd be facing the camera and he'd be like,
well you know,
he wasn't scoring,
he wasn't picking up any girls so he wanted to go but he was being rude about it
and we didn't want to go and he's like,
come on,
let's go and look.
I don't want to go.
It's the whole episode.
Do you think,
do you think those things,
their shows are popular because they allow people to kind of,
it takes the pressure off people.
They feel like they are watching kind of themselves.
What do you think?
It's a trick.
It's just a ropes.
You in it,
it hijacks all of your,
your your normal systems that are set up to monitor actual life and you're
participating in the life that you have no stakes in.
You have nothing in you not thinking involved.
You know,
whether the,
the this guy breaks up with his wife or there's like a lot of those guys that
are the people like men are on that show and a,
they're starting to realize what dumb cunts their wives are.
And they're fucking bailing on them in the middle of the shell.
Like Kelsey Grammer got rid of his wife and middle of the show.
Yeah.
That was part of the show was that she wanted,
you know,
my husband's famous and I'm gonna step out behind his shadow and all of a sudden
she's on and everyone's like,
here's fucking wretched bitch.
What the fuck?
So she was a extreme con during the first episode.
Kelsey Grammer leaves her,
everyone hates it.
A really nice guy by the hay or the
waves of hate that bus were bestowed upon her,
completely changed her personality.
And so then from that season on,
she's super nice to everyone.
Just fake as fuck.
Oh,
nice as pie.
And Kathy,
grandma leaves you.
He's a really nice human beings.
You know,
I never tell you my Kelsey Grammer story.
He fucking,
he did me a solid,
I'll never forget this guy for this.
I'm on a date.
I'm in Nobu in Malibu.
It costs $1 million for dinner there.
And I take this girl out who I'd seen singing and she was beautiful and I just
wanted to get laid because she was such a good singer and so hot.
She couldn't have been less interested in me.
She was looking at me like I was a spore,
but I had done well then how'd you get her out?
I mean,
she kind of liked me.
Then she realized she was just like literally almost yawning through the dinner.
I was like,
I'm not going to get laid and I'm spending fucking my house payments on this
fucking dinner.
Right?
So Kelsey Grammer comes in with a whole bunch of people.
I had done Frazier,
so I Kinda knew him and I had just done inside Schwartz or some shit.
What do you remember that show?
And he had,
and it was on NBC,
the same network as he has,
and he had seen it.
The guide comes over,
the guy comes over,
pretends he knows my name,
but he couldn't remember it.
So hey,
it's Brian.
He goes,
Hey,
I want to come over and say hi.
I loved you in the pilot.
You were great.
And you were so great on Frasier,
thanks for doing it.
And he basically was making me look good for this girl.
He was so clearly,
he was so clearly throwing me the ball.
It was so I could tell he was doing it for me.
And it's called Jihadi.
Yeah.
And cuts.
It cuts it.
We used to call it now.
Yeah.
When someone blows you up,
like if I saw Brian,
you see Brian talking to some girls over in jihad?
Yes.
That's what a friend does.
Yeah.
And the dude did it for me and he barely knew me.
I'd just done a show in stuff and,
and,
and I'll never forget him for that.
And that makes him,
and he was such a fucking great guy.
Anyway,
everybody loves the guy.
But I mean,
I was like,
what a fucking cool guy.
You didn't have to come over to my table and do that for me.
But you did this one guy and I got,
and by the way,
I got laid on the sun and the fucking piece.
I was young,
I was young.
I'm kidding with this girl,
but I don't know the ones that this girl that wasn't,
yes,
she meant did it clearly change?
It's about face bro.
Really?
That's what I'm saying.
I didn't even make it home.
Wow.
Do you guys see the commercial with Brad Pitt's brother?
He's now Doug pit.
You know,
he's now the host
virgin wouldn't make a bet.
Come on.
Virgin Mobile.
Uh,
Australia.
He's the main host and I see that he's a little brother and he looks creepily
like him.
Like as if this guy got hit by a car and there were twins in the system.
Wait,
what do you want?
Let me find the real commercial with for that.
Somebody that's a joke.
I can tell you that's a joke.
No,
it's,
it's real.
They had him on the today show yesterday
or two days ago.
Uh,
here.
Here he is.
Brad.
Pick brother.
Okay,
well why are you looking at that?
There's another thing I wanted to talk about when with gang rapes.
Have you heard about what happened in Ohio?
No.
Speaking of a gang rapes,
there's a,
there was a high school gang
rape with these guys,
drugged up this girl,
this one guy,
um,
apparently the girl broke up with him so he's like a no whore breaks up with me
and like put it on his Twitter.
Right.
And like they put like really horrific shit on her Twitter.
These high school football kids and they would go around,
they called themselves the rape grew.
That's what everybody called them.
Nice guys.
And they would drug girls and gang rape,
bumped cheese.
And they took this girl,
this guy's girlfriend,
they drugged her up and they took her to several parties.
Not One,
but several parties.
She's completely unconscious and they fucked her.
And then they made a video and this is all anonymous bringing all the shit out
because they found out there was a big cover up in this town because this is a
you,
we talked about that,
the area of the town where it was,
yeah.
What was it was the areas,
Steubenville,
well,
there's a video and in the video that they just released,
these kids are bragging about the rape and about how dead the girl was while
they were fucking her in her butt and she had it like she was,
she was dead or the no js while she was dead.
And he's,
he jokes about it for 10 15 minutes fucking piece of shit.
You got to pull the video up because it'll,
it'll,
it'll shock you when you find out that this was about a gang rape and then you
see these guys doing this.
It's going to,
well they're,
they're done for the rest of their life.
Good Joe.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Definitely.
Luck getting a job now.
You fucking did it.
Definitely.
But split.
It's also like,
like I did crazy shit as a kid.
I never let that,
that,
that's just a d.
That's just the definition of a fucking asshole.
Yeah.
Just a bad human being.
Just a shoe,
a bad egg.
Like a dirty,
a d,
a sick dog.
It's,
it's one of the,
one of the darkest shit.
It makes me sick.
It's one of the darkest things I've ever seen in my life.
Man.
It's really hard.
It's a,
it's really hard to watch.
Um,
this,
uh,
this kid was just like sitting there with his buddies,
just joking back and forth and laughing,
you know,
it's um,
yeah,
it's bad.
It's just hard to imagine.
It might not be up anymore.
You'll 17 year old boy.
No,
no,
it's there.
It's still there.
Pull up,
uh,
Ohio state,
Ohio high school students joking about.
Yeah,
I got it.
Gang rape.
Yeah.
Oh.
Bernese.
I Logan said a cell phone leads last week by hacktivist group.
Anonymous has added fuel to the fire surrounding an alleged rape in,
in Ohio town.
A group of high school football players is accused of raping and kidnapping.
A 16 year old girl who was allegedly drugged,
taking a numerous parties,
assaulted and urinated on last August.
Now a new piece of evidence in the case shows the teens laughing and joking
about the alleged events.
And we must warn you,
it might make you uncomfortable.
She's bored,
she's dead,
or
he raped her harder than that comp rate.
Marcellus wall.
And a simple fix.
The video was allegedly posted youtube the night of the incident along with
Twitter posts and pictures taken by those who were at the parties where the girl
was being dragged.
The Daily Mail explained to the Ohio town is torn by the case with some
supporting the girl in her accusations and others taking the sides of the
players claiming she made up the horrific events to hurt the football program so
far.
Two football players,
that's not bad for their reputation at all to say that you've been
yeah and urinated on and,
and,
and then you get the guys bragging about it.
Here's
what we do this though,
but it's an important point that we had talked about before Brian,
about that like anonymous is like the person who's,
I mean they are the,
the real group with morals and again,
they're proving this mean this is,
they go after shit man.
When they find out that someone did something fucked up like this,
it was some chick that drown a bunch of puppies and threw him in the river.
They found out who that fucking bitch was.
They went after her.
They found out who she was.
They put all of her information online.
They contacted the police and this the same thing with this.
These all these videos are coming out because of anonymous,
you know,
and there's a lot of people that don't want to get behind an anonymous.
They think they're vigilantes when justice is not being done through traditional
methods,
isn't it someone's fucking responsibility who has power to do something?
They're doing the the job of a,
of the police.
They're doing the job of someone who looks after citizens.
You are,
you have a daughter,
man.
Could you imagine if this is your daughter and you have to find out about this
this way?
I'd fucking have to go buy myself a machine.
It's unbelievably sick,
but this is being glossed over by this fucking town.
If you look into the story behind it,
I looked into it even more after we talked about it and just read all the shit
and then watch this video and I like this is,
I don't understand how you gloss over a fucking like something like that because
it's financially,
financially,
how much money?
It's devastating.
That's happening.
It's like,
it's like when,
when those guys knew that he was fucking young guys,
here's what you do,
young boys,
when you find out somebody,
when you see somebody fucking a 10 year old or whatever,
it wasn't that shower.
I don't know how old the kid was you.
You put a towel around the kid and then you go right to the fucking cops.
You turn that guy in it.
Fuck your football program there.
There is a point where we're things,
stop where you go.
It's called game over.
You Go,
hold on.
I,
it doesn't matter what that nothing else matters.
Don't go,
Yay,
they,
he raped a kid.
But you can't.
There's no,
but after that.
But what is making,
what does making boys willing to do that?
I was never willing to do that when I was,
he,
it's mob mentality with one bad egg and a bunch of weak kids or just to get
boys.
You don't know what they're doing.
I don't know the difference.
They don't they,
it's like it's camaraderie and they,
they,
they're,
they're fucking and aggression and they haven't yet processed because they're
boys and they,
they,
they had,
their brain isn't completely teenagers do crazy shit.
He's in.
Is there an argument that this,
there's a a like a meathead jock mentality that's cultivating.
I don't know that it's,
I don't know that sports
cause you to do that.
I think it's just,
it's,
it's usually a couple,
one,
two,
three really bad kids are just shitty people who are too fucking dumb or too
aggressive too.
They want them to be super aggressive and super acid fighters that are make for
better,
better football players.
The more aggressively go out and take it.
If they're like real sweet and kind,
they're not going to play crazy violent football boys.
They found young teenagers.
The reason that young somebody said,
if you put,
if you took every teenage boy from the age of like 14 to 21 and put them in
jail,
we'd have zero crime in this country.
Is the idea is that when,
when they're,
when a male brain is forming your,
you deal mainly with the frontal Cortex,
right?
Not In the middle brand,
in the back brain,
whatever it is.
I can't remember.
That's not true.
That's the idea.
The idea of being that the idea is crazy.
Who are,
the idea is they're impulsive,
they're fucking,
they're hyper aggressive.
You know,
there's certainly that.
But what I'm saying is that in that sort of culture,
that's,
look,
man,
there's a cultivated sort of an attitude about,
I'm not saying that encourages rape,
but I'm saying that when you have a bunch of kids that,
and they're not getting the proper guidance and they're encouraged to be crazy
and aggressive.
I was,
I'm aggressive.
I was crazy aggressive.
I've always been an aggressive person.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm as aggressive as anybody as a teenager.
I never in a million years would have been gang raped or establish that.
Why?
So why is it that they can go and I think typically it's just,
uh,
usually,
whatever you want to call it.
A bad kid.
No,
no,
no.
I can't just be one kid.
It's not,
there's no group.
It's probably a group.
But I'm,
why are you saying that it's one kid that starts this fire and then everyone
else's catches fire,
I guess crazy real leader in a group of bad guy in the,
in the group.
My,
my guess is that's usually how boys delineate authority.
There's always one alpha male,
you know,
that's interesting.
And this,
uh,
in this situation,
I,
you know,
I have a feeling that they're sort of a detachment that they all sort of
cultivate,
you know,
that this,
uh,
I agree,
this angry,
aggressive detachment and some of that has to do with the ideas behind kicking
people's asses and going out and being successful in,
especially someone that's something as detached as like football or it's sort of
violent,
but it's violent.
This sort of weird,
tricky way where you're allowed to like run into each other and fuck them up
and,
but you're not really fighting,
you know?
So there's no,
there's,
there's not the same Marshall discipline and the things that are involved in,
in,
in competing in that sort of one on one endeavor.
It's a different sort of group in town.
The Capstone Sports,
cause I think you have a lot of cut a lot of places that those men in India,
I'd never played football.
I probably never played sports and they would probably getting raped themselves
too though.
I mean,
you know,
you're dealing with a lot of it in those situations.
You're dealing in incredibly impoverished places.
Happens to men too.
When you have one strong leader and,
and some bad people involved,
then you have a couple of guys that want to be included and be cool and they're
dorks and they,
you know,
I don't know.
It's just how someone raise a
son that's capable of doing that to a girl.
I mean,
is it growing up without sisters or the,
you know,
maybe not having the love for your mother or not realizing that girls are the
same and are maybe subhuman some way?
Well,
I'm hoping that like the Neat Delhi thing that what you're dealing with in
Steubenville,
Ohio,
wherever the fuck it is,
is you're dealing with a bunch of backwards ass holes that aren't getting the
full version of the world yet.
And that because of this and because of what anonymous has done and expose all
this,
that it's gonna make that impossible to ever happen again.
And the kids are going to be aware of that shit and the family's going to be
aware of that shit and no one's going to be,
no one's ever going to try to pull anything on it that off again.
Cause he didn't know they can't.
I hope so.
I do think that when you do that,
what those guys did to that girl,
I think it's very similar to what those guys would do to another guy with a
baseball bat.
They would soon to anybody.
Yeah,
it's fine.
It's an act of violence.
So,
so whether it's the girls,
the target or some guy walking down the street who's a different color or
wearing a weird shirt,
that mob mentality with young guys happens a lot has always happened.
It's the same.
The thing that allows someone to beat someone to death from because they're
wearing a jersey from the wrong teams.
Like that guy in la,
that's a tribal thing and almost to death,
it is almost the same thing.
It's like we're all together against everybody else.
Where do you get fucker?
But,
and it's almost like the way you prove that you're with the group is to engage
in these immoral activities that you would never do to someone who is a member
of the group.
You're trying to one up each other.
I factor in the air looking at Ip dot.
So crazy bro.
Pissed at her butt,
right?
Yeah.
It's fucking not to hear those stories when you were younger.
I remember my buddy was like,
dude.
And John went to New York and he had sex with this dual ochre and he was banging
her in the ass and we could have here going Ah,
and handed out laughing and I was like looking at him going on.
I don't know if that's that funny dude.
I don't feel,
I kinda feel bad for that girl.
I just think a lot of times it can also be like a level of compassion.
You're either born with it sometimes or other people don't have the ability to,
to have empathy as much empathy with somebody else.
It's also those formative years too.
It's really terrifying about that kid.
And that video was laughing and bragging about the girl getting raped.
What's really terrifying is that same,
that same boy could easily be put in Afghanistan and given a gun.
Fuck you doing man.
Sorry.
Yeah.
What are you trying to do man?
I didn't do that on purpose.
The um,
that could have been easily,
you know,
like that one guy who wound up going fucking crazy and gun down.
A bunch of people had been there forever.
The other thing is that same boy may with the right guidance have been putting
all that aggression into something productive.
The,
when you look at that kid right now at 17 his life has done,
I don't think,
I don't,
how do you,
how do you come away with,
you know,
I guess when he's 30 or 40 you know,
things wash away,
but for that he's going to be brought up on charges,
rape
and your life is pretty much at that point going to take a major turn and most
likely the amount of public pressure that's going to be on trying these guys as
adults is going to be huge.
You're not,
they're not.
No one's going to want them to get away with this.
They're laughing about this.
They gonna want to send a message.
Hey,
yeah.
It's like we got to figure out a way to stop the competition.
Like this idea that there's an us and them in society and whether it's an us and
them,
whether it's Ohio people,
Shit on Kentucky,
people are,
it's men that should on women or gays or shit on straights or blacks against
whites.
We have this division,
this arm,
so sort of like clan mentality gone wrong division in,
in,
in human beings where we're willing to do fucked up shit to certain groups.
If we decide there the Taliban or we decide they're the enemy or their fags or
they're girls,
they're bitches or their blacks or whatever,
I would suggest that it's getting better,
not worse.
And I would suggest the world has less brutal in that regard than it used to be.
And the reason I say that is because there are eyes on it and it's becoming
easier and easier to identify and understand how similar you are to those people
over there.
Those people over there also have the internet.
Those people over there speak a common language.
I'm being offered standup gigs in Dubai and in Lebanon and in south.
I suggest you not take it.
I'm not going to,
I'm just saying that put your ass in jail.
I'm just,
I'm just saying that,
that it's interesting that you have people there that want to laugh too
sometimes at the same stuff we are connecting.
We are,
we are developing a neuro consciousness.
I mean,
I don't know how long it's going to take,
but it feels that we are,
like I said before,
being nudged in the same direction toward each other.
Eh,
having virtual experiences,
almost of what it's like to be each other,
that's becoming easier than it is.
It scares me the most about that kid is what made that kid could that have been
me if I grew up in that kid's household?
If I had that Kid's dad,
if I had that kid's mom and that kids brothers and I lived in that kid's town,
would I be him?
That's a good question.
It's an absolute real question.
You know,
drunk.
You're trying to,
you're,
you don't,
you're not looking at the girl as a human being.
She's drunk.
She's passed out.
You're just going to have sex with her because he,
it's not hurting her.
It's all that stuff.
You know,
you're 17 you're a fucking retard.
There's a part in my act,
what's the true story where I talk about being on a boat and being,
I was really,
really high and these dolphins were playing next to the boat and through this
law,
I won't give you the whole bit,
but I realized something that it's very possible that everybody is exactly the
same at the core,
but we're just live in these different existences with different biologies and
different personalities and different sexual needs and wants and different life
experiences.
And I thought about it and I thought like one of the best ways to treat people
is to treat people as if they're you living another life.
If every
person you run into literally is you living another life,
if you live my life,
you would be me.
And if I lived your life,
you,
you know,
if I lived your life,
I would be here.
I would be,
I would be you and every exact I've,
I've,
I would have your experiences in your jeans and your,
and if we could get people to somehow or another consider that.
That would be like the greatest idea for religion ever.
Instead of a religion based on the idea that there's some crazy motherfucker
that brings people back from the dead and turns water into wine and if you eat
the wrong fruit,
you're fucked instead of that guy.
How about the idea that all of us are the same and we really could get so much
more done?
One of the tenants of Christianity I think is interesting is that,
and one of the main tenants,
well one of the things that Christ said is all you have to do is do unto others
as you'd have them do unto you.
Yes,
that was,
he said if you do that,
if you hold,
if you will,
that's abstract.
It's treat them right
as you would like them to treat you.
What I'm saying is a,
treat them as if they were you.
If that,
if it was you living another life,
if we really are all one than I am you and you are me and it sounds hippy as
fuck.
But if people could figure out how to think like that,
I think that would be the real life changer.
That would be the real game changer.
And it could happen and that also would get rid of all the fuck you was.
All the fuck heads would be held accountable the same way you're held
accountable,
which is like when I was saying about that video,
one of the things that disturbs me the most is I know that I am a flawed human
being and especially at times in my life when I was younger,
I've,
I've been capable of doing crazy things that were regrettable and that I got
through it without doing anything like that.
I got through life without committing any felonies or doing any horrible crimes,
but that's just lucky.
I could have been in the wrong environment
know,
I was just thinking the other day,
I remember hitting somebody in her face as hard as I could.
I was in a fight.
I really believe that in that moment I was trying to kill that guy.
You know?
I was trying like when you hit somebody in the face because you're angry at them
in a real fight and you hit him in like you were in a bar or whatever new hit
him,
you're trying to fuck,
I'm so angry I'm trying to kill that fucking dude.
Right.
And they go down.
You stomp them with your exact same,
it's exactly the same mindset.
I just got away with it cause I didn't pumps that hard.
Right.
You know I gave,
I hit him in my hands,
I got girl hands but,
but that's that is that is the,
we have all made decisions,
split second decisions through anger or whatever that could have landed us,
could have changed our lives in a very,
very different way.
And it's a question about,
that
seems to me that a big part of this conversation,
a big part of the issue of like what would allow a person to be to dehumanize a
girl like that.
What would allow a person to to be a serial killer or a school shooter or any of
that.
It all goes down to the heart of the matter,
which is trying to figure out how to get people to respect and treat other
people in a better way.
Saying locally,
one of the guys with their ex too,
so that's something that was what I said,
that guy,
he said,
no bitch breaks up with me,
so he got a draw.
There are two things to think about.
Also,
I also think you'd have to make an account for the fact that first of all,
these events,
the reason you read about them,
we talk about them is because in the grand scheme of things,
they're fairly rare,
right?
When it makes the news,
so it's let,
thank God it's an aberration.
It's a rarity.
We heard.
Did you hear about this?
No,
that I don't hear about that every day.
That's part of the thing,
but I also think that I really believe that the majority of people are,
are good people and kind of do what you say and then the,
it just takes a small fucking handful.
It takes a tiny fraction of the population to ruin it for the rest of us.
Think you said something really important earlier will that people can get used
to almost anything.
You know,
and I think that's what it is.
Like this idea that people can get used to horrific conditions.
They can get used to a lot of fucked up that can each get used to eat and fly
burgers.
You can also use to gang run.
You can also,
because of technology,
isolate yourself from the rest of the world more than you've ever been able to.
You can live a virtual existence.
You can be a young man who sits in his room all day and his only friend is the
internet and video games.
I don't know that that creates a killer of course,
but I do think we live in a world where you can certainly isolate yourself into
a virtual reality where you start to believe the virtual is actual and so now
when you're playing video games all day,
it's just an example.
Now human beings a target because you haven't had any,
you haven't had any interaction with a human being.
It's like Malcolm Gladwell's book where as soon as the Bronx stopped being small
houses where everybody knew each other and they built these huge structures
where everybody was anonymous.
It was much easier to kill somebody to know him.
He didn't know who they were.
There wasn't a connection there.
And so in some ways technology is bringing us together in other ways.
Some people are being left out so that they are completely disconnected and
their only connection is a virtual connection.
Yeah.
Well as virtual,
uh,
technology gets better,
then it becomes even weirder because then the temptation to enter into virtual
realms,
they're going to be more and more satisfying.
Rewarding.
So in the same way where it's almost like a race between these two forces,
that connective force of the Internet,
the ability to bring people together through information and through social
media and then the virtual possibilities,
the possibilities of living into what life of world of Warcraft and,
and call of duty,
you know,
and the idea that that can somehow or another change someone's view on
interacting with people because the way they interact with people on this
fucking case,
killing them all the time,
that's what they're doing like all the time,
right.
That those two forces are kind of duking it out to see like it becomes your
reality,
right?
I mean,
it becomes your reality when you do it over and over again.
Um,
I dunno man.
I think that when you're not having real connections with human beings,
it can probably change it.
Some people,
yeah,
we're a,
we're really not fixed yet.
We're not done.
We're like a work in progress.
These fucking humans,
but yet people want to keep everything the way it is right now.
I don't know.
They learned,
the more they learn about the brain.
You know,
the serial
killers,
that guy was ankle.
He goes,
Dexter's never going to make a serial killer.
Serial killers have different brains.
We know that now.
So sometimes people just have bad brains,
man.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it makes sense.
I mean,
some people have giant dicks.
That's it.
Like me.
Why wouldn't somebody that's a hindrance sometimes.
Why wouldn't some people have fucked up brains?
Some people are nymphomaniacs.
Right?
Brian,
why wouldn't a,
some people fuck you had though?
Of course it does a lot of things.
So it was that the guy yesterday that said that,
um,
no,
no.
He didn't say there wasn't nymphomaniacs what he's saying,
there's no sex addicts saying the evidence for sex addicts,
they're like,
what?
What did it,
it's not sex.
It's making you addicted.
It's compulsive behavior.
And it can manifest itself in playing cards.
It can manifest itself in anything.
It's just like you have compulsive behavior.
So you're compulsive behaviors.
Sexual Holla at your boy bitches,
Brian Cowen.
We'll being appearing.
We'll being appearance.
It was so smooth.
It's almost like a pro.
Brian Callen will be appearing at the punchline in San Francisco.
Not this weekend.
You fuckheads but next weekend,
I don't know who's there this weekend?
16,
17,
18.
They ain't as funny.
Yeah.
Fucks.
Okay.
So go see him.
San Francisco,
you bad ass motherfuckers,
which is one of the greatest cities in the world and it's an awesome place to
perform as is Pasadena,
where we will be tonight.
Um,
Eddie if just got added to the show.
So it's Eddie,
ift,
Brian Red Band,
Sam Tripoli,
Jason t,
Kevin,
Chris,
Christie,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
Jesus fucking Christ.
You can't get any better than that dirty fucks.
She's awesome.
And it's only 15 bucks and then the seats too.
So it's probably sold out every show and a I'm there next week,
most likely,
uh,
with Joey Diaz and Ari Shaffir.
If Joey's wife has the little,
the little noggin.
So a sent Joey out some love.
If not,
it'd be a,
Ari's going to be working on some new shit and uh,
that'll be the main room of the ice house next Friday night,
the 11th.
Um,
thank you everybody for tuning in to podcast as always.
Thanks for all the love and all the positive messages.
We appreciate the fuck out of it and all the intriguing tweets that I get.
I get some fascinating winks.
Um,
really,
really interesting stuff.
And uh,
I I appreciate the shit out of it.
It's really a,
an awesome thing to,
to be connected to a,
I don't know how it all happened but uh,
I am benefiting from it.
We are all benefiting from it as much as you guys are.
So as much as you say it changed your life,
it helps you.
It changed my life too.
It's helping me too.
I would never be able to have these long ass conversations.
Me and Brian,
like we hang out together more than we've ever hung out before because of this.
It's hard to do this thing.
It's great.
Greatest thing ever.
And you can see Brian's podcasts,
you can listen to it.
Rather.
It's called the Brian Callen show,
perfect name.
And,
uh,
you can get that shit on iTunes along with the 10 minute podcast,
which is one of the top three up and coming new podcasts on iTunes.
It got an award.
We got an award to why Brian?
One of the best,
best comedy podcasts in Canada too.
You have fucks.
I Love Candy.
I'm going to Vancouver,
man.
I can't wait.
But when did you add 24th,
25th.
26th.
What are you doing up there?
Y'All can be at company makes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That used to be like,
Yep.
I love it.
I love Canada.
I love Vancouver.
Vancouver is one of the guys who sell out too.
It's so fun.
That's my number one place to bail when the shit hits the Fan America.
Okay.
Coover I'm all over it.
All right.
You fuck sticks?
Um,
we will,
uh,
see you all next week.
We got a,
uh,
next week is an action packed week.
Adam Hunter just going to be on a,
Steve Volk is going to be on the Brian.
Oh,
Duncan Trussell is going to be on next week,
and maybe even Jimmy Smith if we could work a man who's,
um,
uh,
he does my,
my job for Bella tour.
And these are really good,
dude.
So we're going to talk a talk some MMA,
which Jimmy Smith and a.
All right.
That's it folks.
That's it for the week.
We love the shit out of you and,
uh,
don't change or do change.
Get better.
Get it together.
All right.
That's it.
Yeah.